d'avoir répondu à à
l'invitation de notre
commission d'enquête euh visant
à établir les raisons de la
perte de la souveraineté et de
l'indépendance énergétique euh
de de la France. Euh nous
venons de commencer nos travaux
puisque euh notre commission
s'est installée la semaine
dernière euh que nous avons eu
une première euh audition euh
tout à l'heure avec euh une
anthropologue, un euh de de
l'énergie et euh aujourd'hui
nous cherchons à à brosser de
de façon générale un un le
paysage énergétique euh, de la
France avant progressivement
d'entrer euh, euh, plus en
détail dans dans le dans le
processus euh, décisionnel.
Alors monsieur Jean vous êtes
professeur à Mines ParisTech
vous êtes membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat pardon
très récemment vous étiez
alors? Ah, mine Paris euh vous
étiez vous êtes membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat
fondateur du Shift Project,
merci d'avoir euh répondu à
notre demande d'audition dans
des délais extrêmement
contraints euh qui sont liés
euh à l'agenda de
l'installation de notre euh de
notre commission vous êtes euh
par ailleurs euh euh
relativement connue des des
Français euh pour vous exprimer
régulièrement des sur les
sujets d'énergie euh dans les
médias et euh nous allons vous
donc vous donner sans tarder
euh la parole pour nous exposer
euh euh vos votre analyse pour
un propos introductif et puis
ensuite euh il y aura euh des
questions de ma part, du
rapporteur et puis euh de de la
commission mais en en amont,
s'agissant d'une commission
d'enquête et en vertu de
l'article six de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre
mille-neuf-cent-cinquante-huit
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires, vous
devez prêter serment de dire la
vérité, toute la vérité, rien
que la vérité. Monsieur Jean
Colissi, je vous prie donc de
lever la main droite et de
dire, je le je le jure. Je le
jure. Merci et je vous laisse
donc la la parole pour un
propos introductif. Très bien.
Ben en fait mon propos
introductif va être
relativement bref parce que
j'imagine que c'est surtout
vous qui avez des questions.
Euh je vais juste faire euh
deux deux commentaires. Un sur
mes titres et ce au nom duquel
je m'exprime ou pas. Euh et le
deuxième commentaire que je
vais faire c'est sur l'intitulé
même de la commission
d'enquête. Euh en ce qui
concerne mes titres donc je
précise que je ne m'exprime euh
au nom d'aucune euh des
instances pour lesquelles euh
on a envie ici donc je ne suis
pas du tout habilité à
m'exprimer au Haut Conseil pour
le climat , qui est une
présidente qui fait ça très
bien. Je suis pas plus habilité
à m'exprimer euh au nom des
mines euh ni au nom de Carbone
quatre, donc ce que je vais
vous raconter aujourd'hui
n'engage pas Carbone quatre et
ni au nom du GIF Project.
Voilà, ça ça n'engagera que
moi. Euh la deuxième chose que
je souhaite préciser, en ce qui
concerne le titre même de votre
commission euh la France n'a
jamais été indépendante
énergétique ment depuis qu'elle
a quitté l'air des énergies
renouvelables. C'est-à-dire que
nous étions indépendants
énergétique ment à l'époque où
nous utilisons exclusivement
euh les pierres bois du sol
français pour construire des
moulins à vent euh les pierres
euh du sol français pour pour
construire des moulins à eau
euh et le bois français euh et
l'herbe française pour faire
avancer des animaux de trait.
Depuis que nous sommes rentrés
dans l'ère des combustibles
fossiles et de l'énergie
nucléaire et des nouvelles
énergies renouvelables et
cetera. En fait nous ne sommes
pas indépendants parce que nous
il y a une espèce d'imbrication
des énergies, je sais pas si
l'historien des énergies qui
est venue ici, c'est
Jean-Baptiste Freso euh non
c'est pas lui mais sinon en
fait il y a une implication des
énergies euh fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
dégager une énergie de façon
euh, individualisée d'un
système elles sont toutes
imbriquées euh, et par exemple
on ne fait pas de réacteur
nucléaire sans métallurgie donc
sans charbon, on ne fait pas de
panneaux photovoltaïques sans
électricité au charbon donc
sans charbon, on ne fait pas on
ne fait pas venir depuis la
Chine sans pétrole parce que il
faut que ça vienne, donc en
fait il y a une imbrication des
énergies aujourd'hui euh, et
sauf à ce qu'un pays maîtrise
sur son sol la totalité à la
fois des sources énergétique s
impliquées, donc la totalité
des actuellement utilisé dans
le monde. Et la totalité des
mines métalliques euh qui sont
nécessaires pour fournir les
dispositifs d'extraction de
l'énergie de l'environnement et
de transformation en des
vecteurs énergétique qui
permettent d'alimenter nos
machines. Eh bien euh on ne
peut pas parler d'indépendance
énergétique ou de souveraineté
énergétique . Donc en fait
aucun pays ne la possède
totalement euh l'Arabie
Saoudite a plus de pétrole que
nous, mais elle a pas de mine
de fer. Euh donc si elle était
euh à frontière fermée, sans
aucune communication avec
l'extérieur, elle ne pourrait
pas exploiter son pétrole.
Voilà, donc c'était un petit,
une petite remarque
préliminaire euh pour dire que
les mots ayant un sens, enfin
en tout cas j'imagine qu'ils en
ont un dans la commission euh
d'un titre euh de la commission
d'enquête. Je voulais juste
faire remarquer que
l'indépendance ça n'existe pas,
stricto sensu. Et que la bonne
question pour moi me semble
être pour euh l'ensemble du
système énergétique de savoir
de qui on dépend. Dans quelles
proportions? Avec quelle
aptitude à se retourner si
jamais on a un problème avec
les gens dont on dépend, Voilà,
c'est ça les bonnes questions
euh et donc c'est des questions
qui sont nécessairement
quantifiées et calendées euh un
débat euh c'est pas du tout
agressif ce que je veux dire
hein mais avoir un débat
philosophique sur
l'indépendance euh en fait
c'est très intéressant euh le
soir passé vingt-trois heures
mais sinon dans dans l'absolu
ça n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
pratique. Et je vais finir ce
petit exposé éliminaire en
rappelant que la France quand
on regarde ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie finale euh
c'est-à-dire l'énergie qui
alimente les machines qui nous
rendent la vie si douce, qu'il
s'agisse des ascenseurs, des
tractopelles, des trains ou des
laminoirs euh l'essentiel de
l'énergie qui rentre dans une
machine en France qui nous rend
un service quel qu'elle soit,
que ce soit de la mobilité euh
de et cetera, c'est des
combustibles fossiles. Euh et
que la France sauf erreur de ma
part, ne possède plus du tout
de de gaz sur son sol et euh,
possède 1 % enfin extra extrait
de l'environnement, 1 % du
pétrole euh, qu'elle qu'elle
consomme. Je vais également
faire un un petit rappel euh,
j'avais dans alors pas pas dans
l'hémicycle ni dans cette salle
mais dans une autre salle de
l'Assemblée il y a très très
longtemps participer à un
colloque organisé par Yves
Cochet qui avait fait rigoler
tout le monde à l'époque euh,
sur le pic de production du
pétrole euh, ça devait être il
y a une quinzaine d'années je
crois euh, je voudrais rappeler
que le pic de production du
pétrole depuis est passé en ce
qui concerne le pétrole
conventionnel, c'est-à-dire que
tout ce qui n'est pas le
l'américain et les sables
bitumineux canadiens et un
maximum en 2008 dans le monde,
il y a un lien direct avec la
ce qu'on a appelé la crise des
subprimes que depuis ça décline
et que en ce qui concerne
l'Europe, l'Europe est en
approvisionnement contraint à
la baisse sur son pétrole
depuis cette date. Ça c'est
quelque chose qui est
géologique, d'accord, que ça
nous plaise ou que ça nous
plaise pas, ça va s'accélérer
euh, dans les décennies qui
viennent et en particulier il y
a un travail très complet qui a
été fait par le chiffre projet
qui est public hein, qui est
disponible sur notre site euh,
qui porte sur les possibilités
de production de pétrole sous
seule contrainte géologique des
16 premier fournisseurs de
l'Europe qui sont par ailleurs
les 16 premiers producteurs
mondiaux hors Brésil et Canada
et la conclusion de ce travail
qui a été mené par deux anciens
cadres dirigeants de Total et
pas n'importe lesquels
puisqu'il s'agissait de la
personne qui était en charge de
l'évaluation des gisements et
la personne qui était en charge
de l'exploration c'est que la
production de nos 16 premiers
fournisseurs devrait être
divisé par deux d'ici à 2050 ce
qui veut dire que leurs
exportations vers l'Europe vont
être divisées par n'importe
quoi entre 2 et vingt. Donc de
la perte de souveraineté sur le
pétrole faut s'attendre à en
avoir et pas qu'un peu en ce
qui concer le gaz, le Chic
Project va publier en novembre
dans quelques jours là euh, un
travail similaire qu'on a fait
sur le gaz euh confié à des
personnes de du même tabac avec
des données qui sont en qui
sont issues du même endroit,
c'est-à-dire une base de
données de l'ensemble des
gisements de pétrolier de gaz
dans le monde euh auxquels on a
euh à laquelle on a eu accès.
Et le résultat de ce travail
c'est que le pic de production
pour le gaz dans le monde dans
son ensemble c'est
deux-mille-trente euh celui
pour la mer du Nord c'était
deux-mille-cinq. Donc si on
ajoute à ça le fait que le
charbon est en dépression
géologique en Europe depuis
1950, enfin depuis euh les
années 50 en gros hein, en fait
sur toutes les énergies
fossiles, l'Europe étant, entre
guillemets, perte de
souveraineté depuis, 2005 pour
le gaz, euh deux-mille-huit
pour le pétrole, euh et euh les
années 50 pour le charbon. Mais
avant même qu'il y ait des
sujets de climat . Voilà, c'est
dans ce ce, donc il faut bien
voir que en fait, euh sur les
énergies fossiles qui sont le
premier moteur de la
civilisation dans lequel nous
vivons, euh la question de la
perte de souveraineté elle est
déjà à l'oeuvre depuis
longtemps, et ça va
s'accélérer. Et ça va se
traduire en contraction de flux
de toute nature euh que l'on a
l'habitude de résumer
classiquement euh sous l'angle
euh PIB mais voilà on va on va
avoir un sujet euh de
contraction des fluides de
toute façon euh qu'on en ait
envie ou pas. Merci beaucoup
pour euh ce propos introductif
qui qui pose tout de suite le
le cadre. Euh moi j'aurais
j'aurais du coup quelques
quelques questions avant avant
de laisser la la parole au au
rapporteur. Euh d'abord euh une
première question finalement
au-delà de la de la
souveraineté et de
l'indépendance, aujourd'hui la
dans dans le débat public et et
dans le dans la situation aussi
euh dans laquelle on se trouve
dans les et dans les
contraintes pour pour les choix
énergétique à venir, il y a la
question du climat et et elle
est même centrale euh et donc
du du cycle carbone euh, très
long sur les énergies fossiles,
plus court sur euh, la
biomasse, absent euh, sur euh,
sur euh, les énergies
renouvelables ou ou sur euh, ou
sur euh, le nucléaire. Quelle
est quelle est pour vous euh, à
l'échelle du climat le le le
pas de temps acceptable du
cycle carbone. Alors pourquoi
est-ce que le bois serait
acceptable alors que le charbon
ne l'est pas? Est-ce que vous
pouvez un peu nous nous
détailler ça? Oui alors une
toute petite euh, remarque
incidente sur votre question en
fait les énergies renouvelables
et le nucléaire ne sont pas
sans carbone si on regarde en
analyse de cycle de vie puisque
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
il faut du charbon pour faire
la mé il faut de la pétrochimie
pour faire de enfin de la
chimie organique pour faire la
chimie euh à l'amont et cetera.
Après il faut compter euh et
euh le résultat du des comptes
n'est pas le même en ce qui
concerne les différentes
énergies renouvelables euh le
nucléaire et cetera. La le pas
de temps acceptable euh en
général on raisonne dans le
domaine climatique au pas de
temps de l'année, c'est-à-dire
que à partir du moment où une
émission et une reprise de
l'atmosphère ont lieu la même
année, on considère que c'est
neutre. C'est ça le, c'est ça
en général euh ce qu'on ce
qu'on alors en ce qui concerne
les combustibles fossiles, les
combustibles fossiles stockent
du carbone qui a été retiré à
l'atmosphère il y a quelques
dizaines, à quelques centaines
de millions d'années. Euh c'est
à peu près le temps qu'il faut
pour faire du gaz, du charbon
ou du pétrole à partir de
résidus de vie ancienne, des
fougères qui ont poussé au
carbonifère pour le charbon et
du plancton qui s'est développé
dans la mer euh n'importe quand
entre il y a 5 millions
d'années pour une petite partie
mais surtout n'importe quand,
entre 100 et 400 millions
d'années euh pour le pétrole et
le gaz, puis ces résidus de vie
ancienne ont été enfouis par la
technologie des plaques sous le
sol euh gentiment euh
distillées par les par la
géothermie et tout ça a pris
dizaines, à quelques centaines
de millions d'années, ce qui
veut dire que quand on déstocke
ce carbone accumulé, ces poches
de soleil anciennes, comme dit
très joliment il y a Arthus
Bertrand euh, dans
l'atmosphère, quand on les
déstocke et qu'on les remet
dans l'atmosphère, on crée une
asymétrie entre le rythme
auquel euh, la vie peut
reprendre du carbone, de
l'atmosphère et le rythme
auquel nous on déstocke euh, le
carbone qui avait été
anciennement stocké. Pour la
biomasse, en fait, la biomasse
n'est pas nécessairement neutre
en carbone, c'est toute la
difficulté du décompte. Ça
dépend dans quel stock on tape.
Euh pour que la biomasse soit
considérée comme neutre en
carbone, il faut taper dans un
stock qui, si on ne tapait pas
dedans, serait à l'équilibre
avec chaque année une partie
des arbres qui meurent, on va
dire, euh et euh de jeunes
arbres qui repoussent. Et à
partir du moment où on prélève
dans un stock qui est à
l'équilibre, euh moins que ce
qu'on appelle la crue forestier
annuelle, euh c'est-à-dire la
quantité de biomasses qui se
forment par photosynthèse. À ce
moment, on considère qu'on a
affaire à une énergie
renouvelable. Si on prélève
plus, à ce moment, on a affaire
à de la déforestation et c'est
pas du tout compter dans les
énergies renouvelables, c'est
compter. Et alors c'est toute
la difficulté, c'est que dans
une partie des réglementations
qui poussent à l'utilisation de
la biomasse, en fait, on est
pas capable de mettre des
seuils. C'est-à-dire qu'on
n'est pas capable de dire, on
va favoriser l'appel à la
biomasse jusqu'à tel niveau,
parce que après on bascule dans
la déforestation. Et par
ailleurs, il y a quelque chose
dont on sait très mal tenir
compte euh, dans ce genre de
cas de figure, qui est les les
effets dominos ou les effets de
transfert. Euh, je vais vous
donner un exemple. Aujourd'hui,
on considère que le colza qu'on
fait pousser en France euh
faire des agrocarburants c'est
de la biomasse neutre en
carbone. Mais moi je pourrais
vous dire, on pourrait très
bien à la place de ce colza euh
ne pas faire pousser de colza,
diminuer la taille des voitures
et par ailleurs à la place du
colza, faire pousser du soja et
de la luzerne et éviter d'en
importer du Brésil et comme ça
éviter de la déforestation.
Bon, donc vous voyez euh dans
le deuxième cas de figure, je
peux considérer que le colza
par effet d'éviction empêche de
mettre en France des cultures
qui elles vont engendrer de la
déforestation. est-ce que je
considère que Skolza, il est
neutre en carbone ou pas? Ben
vous voyez euh ce genre de donc
il y a plein de questions de
méthodes qui sont très
compliquées euh quand il s'agit
de faire appel à la biomasse et
en tout état de cause, si on
raisonne à l'échelle
planétaire, au moment où
actuellement, à l'échelle
planétaire, la euh la la la
terre est en déforestation. Ce
qui veut dire que à chaque fois
que on met quelque part une
culture énergétique ben on peut
se dire que comme c'est la
culture marginale, c'est la
c'est la dernière qu'on met en
oeuvre, c'est elle qui est euh
responsable d'une partie de la
déforestation qu'on pourrait
éviter, sinon si on mettait pas
en oeuvre cette culture, voilà.
donc c'est c'est c'est
compliqué euh les raisonnements
sur la biomasse. Euh il y a il
y a rien de très simple
là-dedans. Euh du coup est-ce
que euh pour euh décarboner euh
à l'échelle de de la planète à
notre euh, notre économie?
Est-ce que euh le seul chemin
c'est celui de la de la
décroissance? Je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne va
pas réussir à éviter et en fait
quand on regarde les flux
physiques, c'est quelque chose
dans lequel nous sommes déjà en
Europe depuis deux-mille-sept
euh deux-mille-huit,
c'est-à-dire le passage de la
de l'approvisionnement, enfin
du maximum de
l'approvisionnement pétrolier.
Si on regarde les flux physique
de quoi je parle, je parle par
exemple de la quantité de
mètres carrés qu'on construit
en Europe, qui est passée par
un maximum en 2007, que nous
n'avons plus jamais atteint
depuis. Euh je parle des tonnes
chargées dans les camions qui
sont passés par un maximum en
2007 et qui n'a pas été atteint
de nouveau depuis. Je parle
éventuellement de la production
industrielle. Euh voilà, quand
vous regardez donc euh encore
que la production industrielle
elle est mesurée en euros. Donc
là déjà il y a une convention
euh on est plus dans les unités
strictement physiques comme des
mètres carrés ou des tonnes. Là
c'est beaucoup plus facile.
Donc il faudrait mesurer la
production industrielle en
tonne aussi mètres cube ou
enfin en quelque chose de
physique et là on aurait une
réponse qui serait euh beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus claire mais
euh il n'empêche que un certain
nombre d'indicateurs physiques
ou de proxy, d'indicateurs
physiques en fait sont déjà en
décrue en Europe depuis
2-mille7, deux-mille-huit, ce
qui signifie qu'en fait la
décroissance on s'en rend pas
compte mais on est déjà dedans.
Alors quand je dis on s'en rend
pas compte, les élites urbaines
comme nous s'en rendent pas
compte, parce que nous on fait
partie des préservés du
système, vous et moi, euh on
vit dans un endroit qui est
loin des flux physiques donc en
ville, octobre, les vêtements
arrivent dans le magasin, euh
la arrive au supermarché, enfin
on se rend pas bien compte de
ce qu'il y a à la. Et donc euh
c'est voilà, donc on n'est on
n'est pas on n'est pas les
premiers, j'ai envie de dire, à
se rendre compte avec nos sens,
et l'essence ça compte quand
même chez les animaux que nous
sommes, euh on est pas les
premiers à se rendre compte
avec nos sens, de ce qui est en
train de se passer, mais en
fait, on est déjà dans une
espèce de décru larvé euh en
Europe et les Italiens se
rendent très bien compte euh
les Espagnols et les Portugais
s'en rendent parfaitement
compte aussi. Et c'est
malheureusement quelque chose
qui va s'accélérer parce que
les combustibles fossiles qui
sont eux-mêmes ont décru subi
joue un rôle tellement central
dans l'émergence de la
civilisation dans laquelle nous
vivons, que cette décrue ne
sera pas compensée par aucune
autre forme d'énergie
décarbonée dans les temps euh,
compte tenu des ordres de
grandeur qui sont en jeu. Donc
euh, les énergies décarbonées
vont pouvoir jouer un rôle
d'amortisseur, donc c'est bien
d'en faire, mais euh, ça ne va
pas complètement euh, éviter
une remise en cause euh, parce
que les combustibles fossiles
sont absolument partout à
commencer par le vêtement que
je porte, le la cravate que
vous portez, et cetera, euh, le
vernis de la table sur lequel
je m'appuie, euh, tous les
composants du micro dans lequel
je parle, enfin, il y a du
pétrole résidus de pétrole euh
enfin ou des dérivés du pétrole
plus exactement partout
là-dedans et donc euh faire une
civilisation actuelle sans
combustible fossile,
personnellement je n'y crois
pas. Euh je pense que c'est
juste pas possible. Donc là
donc avec de moins en moins de
combustibles fossiles, oui on
va avoir droit à quelque chose
qui s'apparentera euh alors
appelons-la euh des
croissances, contractions,
sobriété euh tout ça c'est des
c'est des variantes sémantiques
d'un concept qui est exactement
le même, c'est-à-dire qu'on va
devoir faire avec moins, moins
de choses physiques hein. Alors
est-ce que c'est une
catastrophe? Il nous appartient
que la réponse soit non. Euh
est-ce qu'on va échapper? Je ne
crois pas. Pour des raisons
physiques euh aussi. Alors euh
du coup moi je je j'ai deux
questions que je vous pose
encore et puis après je serai
la par au rapporteur. Euh une
sur euh les les ressources
disponibles sur notre euh sur
notre sol. Euh vous avez euh
largement évoqué euh la
quantité euh de ressources
qu'on importe euh qu'ils soient
euh de minerai euh d'énergie
carbonée et cetera. Euh comment
est-ce qu'on mobilise les
ressources sur notre sol? Je
pense y compris aux ressources
minières, euh le lithium par
exemple, des choses comme ça.
Et puis deuxième question
peut-être un peu détaché mais
euh comment comment on
construit aujourd'hui euh des
scénarios énergétique s qui
puissent être euh crédibles? On
on sort d'une période où euh,
on a vu beaucoup de scénarios
énergétique se contredire,
quelle méthode selon vous
est-ce qu'il faudrait qu'on
adopte pour construire des
scénarios énergétique s
crédibles?
aucune de ces deux questions
n'est simple. La sur la
première, euh comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour exploiter des
ressources déjà, encore
faudrait-il qu'on en ait? Euh
vous savez probablement que en
ce qui concerne le charbon, on
a plus grand chose chez nous,
en ce qui concerne le minerai
de fer, on a plus grand chose
chez nous. Je ne sais pas si on
a jamais eu de minerai de
cuivre, mais je pense pas qu'il
nous en reste beaucoup. Euh
donc certes, on a certaines
ressources qu'on peut exploiter
euh donc celle-là euh
éventuellement le, on peut le
faire. Euh par contre, il y en
a d'autres pour lesquels c'est
pas du tout sûr qu'on en ait.
Euh tout court. Après il y a
une deuxième chose qu'il faut
bien voir en ce qui concerne
les ressources métalliques,
c'est que il y a un cercle,
alors je sais pas si je dois
l'appeler euh vicieux ou en
tout cas euh d'asservissement.
Euh entre l'énergie et les tout
simplement parce que avec le
temps, la teneur en métal des
minerais baisse et ça veut dire
que il faut de plus en plus
d'énergie pour produire une
tonne d'un métal donné. Euh
pour vous donner un exemple, si
ma mémoire ne me fait pas trop
défaut, euh dans les premières
mines de cuivre qui ont été
exploitées dans le monde, et
notamment la mine de Rio Tinto,
qui a donné son nom euh ensuite
au groupe minier éponyme qui se
trouve en Espagne, euh je crois
qu'au début de l'exploitation
minière, il y avait de l'ordre
de 15 à 20% de cuivre en poids
euh dans le minerai.
aujourd'hui la teneur moyenne
en cuivre, en pois dans le
minerai des mines exploitées
dans le monde, c'est zéro 4 %.
Et donc on est descendu de
vingt à zéro quatre. Et il y a
un mouvement général de baisse
de la teneur en métaux, de
toutes les mines euh qu'on
exploite dans le monde. Et
c'est évidemment pour cette
raison-là que une partie des
mines françaises ont été
abandonnées, parce qu'il y a
encore un peu de ressources en
France, mais que les mines
françaises ont été abandonnées.
Euh tout simplement parce que
la teneur devenait trop basse
et que du coup, c'était pas
rentable euh en compétition
avec euh d'autres gisements
dans le monde qui étaient plus
intéressants. Pour accéder au
pour accéder aux métaux euh, il
faut de l'énergie et euh, les
ressources qu'on peut
éventuellement avoir en France,
elles sont conditionnées
nécessairement à la quantité
d'énergie dont on peut disposer
pour accéder aux métaux en
question et par ailleurs, au
gisement de départ, à
l'inventaire de départ. on
restera nécessairement
dépendant pour partie de choses
qui ne viennent pas de France.
Quand on regarde par exemple
les quantités de cuivre euh qui
sont impliquées dans le
développement de tout ce qui
est électrique, il est évident
qu'en France on peut pas
déployer euh quoi que ce soit
de significatif comme mode
renouvelable ou même pas
renouvelable euh et comme euh
usage aval électrique sans
importer du cuivre. C'est pas
possible, hein. Alors ce sera
peut-être facile, ce sera
peut-être difficile, j'en sais
rien. Euh sur le cuivre, il y a
une euh information qui a été
publiée par l'agence
internationale de l'énergie il
y a pas très longtemps, 10 ans
que mines de cuivre en
fonctionnement dans le monde et
celles qui sont en cours de
développement, donc en cours de
développement, ça veut dire que
les infrastructures
d'exploitation du minerai sont
en cours de construction,
passeraient leur pic euh entre
maintenant et dans deux ans. Et
euh pour rajouter des nouvelles
mines, c'est-à-dire pour que
des nouveaux projets voient le
jour, il faut compter entre 10
et 15 ans. Hein? Voilà, donc il
y a un petit sujet, alors ça
m'amène du coup à la deuxième
question, qui est comment
est-ce qu'on fait des scénarios
crédibles? Eh ben la réponse,
c'est c'est très compliqué. Euh
au chiffre Project, on avait
modestement fait un discours de
la méthode sur les scénarios
électriques qui nous a valu
ensuite d'avoir des dialogues
très nourris et très fructueux
avec sur la scénarisation
électrique donc nous on avait
pas proposé un scénario, on
avait proposé euh un mode de
réalisation des scénarios en
disant pour que le scénario
soit complet et que le décideur
arrive à y retrouver ses
petits, il faut absolument euh
prendre position sur tel point
tel point, tel point, tel
point, tel point, tel point,
tel point et bien préciser ce
qui est une donnée d'entrée, ce
qui est une donnée de sortie,
hein, voilà. Alors dans les
scénarios énergétique , il y a
aujourd'hui une faiblesse qui
est partagée par à peu près
tous les scénarios, qui est que
l'économie est une donnée
d'entrée. Dans mon point de vue
l'économie est une donnée de
sortie, c'est parce que nous
avons des ressources que nous
sommes capables d'avoir un
système économique. Donc
l'économie vient d'un système
productif, donc un système
économique. Si il n'y avait pas
d'atomes de fer sur Terre, bah
il y aurait pas d'immeuble, en
tout cas pas d'immeuble tel que
nous les construisons
aujourd'hui avec des armatures
en fer. D'accord? Donc la
disponibilité des ressources
est une condition est un
facteur limitant. De la
production économique. euh du
coup le la la croissance du PIB
c'est une c'est dans ma vision
à moi telle que ça devrait
exister dans l'économie alors
que c'est pas du tout ça hein,
ça devrait être une donnée de
sortie d'un modèle dans lequel
en entrée vous mettez les
ressources disponibles et le
nombre de gens capables de
travailler. Hein, c'est ça que
vous devriez mettre en entrée
puis derrière vous avez une
production économique. Or dans
tous les scénarios énergétique
s que je connais en général
l'économie est une donnée
d'entrée et l'énergie est une
est quelque chose qui est
appelée euh par une économie
dont la création vient de Mars.
Bon. Euh alors une faiblesse
qui est partagée par à peu près
tous les scénarios, y compris
euh le scénario de RTE et une
autre faiblesse dans beaucoup
de scénarios économiques, c'est
qu'on postule que les prix
d'aujourd'hui sont prédictifs
de l'absence de limites ou de
limites sur les quantités de
demain, dit autrement si ça
vaut pas cher aujourd'hui,
c'est que demain on en aura
sans limites. Bon, et ça c'est
une deuxième faiblesse puisque
euh malheureusement les prix
d'hier ne sont absolument pas
prédictifs, des quantités de
demain. Euh on est en train de
le voir en ce moment avec le
gaz, le gaz valait pas cher du
tout il y a un an et demi et ça
veut pas du tout dire que on va
avoir les du gaz sans problème
pour les qui viennent. Donc
c'est celui-ci plus le suivant.
Euh donc et celui d'après du
reste. Donc c'est c'est ça
c'est des faiblesses un peu
partagées par tous les
scénarios, c'est le fait que on
a du mal à désimbrer l'économie
de la partie strictement
physique euh dans les scénarios
énergétique s. Après euh j'ai
envie de dire les autres
faiblesses, elles sont un peu
plus secondaires, mais alors du
coup ça veut dire que les
scénarios énergétique qu'on
fait aujourd'hui, il y en a
aucun qui soit euh résistant à
la récession. C'est-à-dire que
en gros euh si on se trouve
dans un monde dans lequel nos
moyens sont physiques sont en
décroissance, la question
savoir si le scénario
énergétique est toujours
réaliste est une question qui
n'est pas tranchée. Hein, d'une
manière générale, dans
l'ensemble des scénarios, il y
a pas, il y a pas ça. Et ce qui
est très étonnant, c'est que
même les scénarios de sobriété,
par exemple, les scénarios
2-0-cinquante de l'ADEM qui
viennent d'être publiés sont
des scénarios dans lesquels il
y a de la croissance
économique. Voilà, donc de mon
point de vue, à ce niveau-là,
il y a une contradiction.
Monsieur le rapporteur.
Merci, merci Monsieur le
président, merci euh monsieur
Jancovici pour ces premiers
mots euh énergétique euh dans
la continuité des des questions
du président, peut-être euh euh
reprendre ce que vous avez dit
en introduction sur la la
manière dont vous avez qualifié
le l'absence d'indépendance
énergétique de tout temps,
enfin en tout cas depuis très
très longtemps euh euh dans
notre pays et et vous demandez
peut-être de qualifier euh
l'évolution de cette dépendance
euh depuis l'après-guerre.
elle a alors au sens de la
valeur ajoutée, elle a elle a
baissé la dépendance puisque on
a coutume de considérer le
nucléaire comme étant une
production domestique. Alors en
termes de valeur ajoutée, c'est
tout à fait exact. Enfin c'est
très largement exact euh il
faut importer moins d'un euro
d'uranium par méga-watteur
électrique produit avec du
nucléaire en France. Donc
effectivement dans un méga
water nucléaire qui coûte 50
euros euh on peut considérer
que enfin en ordre de grandeur,
on peut considérer que c'est
une part qui est parfaitement
négligeable. Si on raisonne en
termes de dépendance,
c'est-à-dire si l'étranger
n'existait pas, est-ce qu'on
pourrait toujours faire
fonctionner le système
français? À ce moment, on n'est
pas plus indépendants sur le
nucléaire que sur le reste. Par
contre, on n'est pas dépendant
de la même manière, et en
particulier si je compare aux
hydrocarbures on a euh un un un
confort, j'ai envie de dire
temporel qui n'est pas
exactement le même. Euh en ce
qui concerne les hydrocarbures,
comme vous le savez
probablement, on a trois mois
de stock en France. Euh
c'est-à-dire que si demain euh
tous nos fournisseurs nous
coupent les vivres sur le
pétrole, le pays fonctionne
trois mois et puis s'arrête,
alors en fait il s'arrêtera
même bien avant parce que il y
a des stocks stratégiques qu'on
utilisera pas parce que on les
gardera pour euh l'armée euh
les ambulances et je sais pas
quoi euh donc très vite euh le
pays s'arrête. En ce qui
concerne l'uranium on peut
stocker des années de
fonctionnement sur le sol euh
et des années ça laisse un peu
plus de temps pour se retourner
si on a un problème avec un
fournisseur que trois mois.
Voilà. Euh sur le voilà donc en
en gros on a en passant des
hydrocarbures au nucléaire ce
qui est la décision qu'on a
prise euh dans la production
électrique euh dans les années
soixante tante, soixante-dix.
Euh bien évidemment, nous avons
gagné en confort euh strict au
sens. On peut pas dire qu'on
est gagné en indépendance par
contre on a gagné en confort et
on a gagné en part de valeur
ajoutée qui est réalisée sur le
sol français versus euh ce qui
est fait euh à l'étranger. On a
aussi gagné, même si c'était
pas le but à l'époque, mais du
coup, c'est quand même un atout
précieux sur les émissions de
CO2.
Merci beaucoup, est-ce que si
je repense ce que vous venez de
dire en prospectif, ça veut
dire que euh un
réinvestissement de la filière
nucléaire ou bien euh à
technologie euh constante ou
marginalement évolutive si on
prend les EPR ou la technologie
euh différente avec euh les
neutrons rapides ou très
différentes avec la fusion, on
pourrait euh on pourrait euh on
ne gagnerait qu'en confort à
nouveau, mais pas en
indépendance C'est bon? Alors
on ne gâte strict au sens, on
ne gagnerait toujours pas en
indépendance parce que par
exemple pour faire une centrale
nucléaire il faut du chrome, on
n'a pas de chrome en France,
euh il faut du cuivre, on n'a
pas de cuivre en France donc
euh c'est toujours pareil, si
on veut être strict sur les
termes, non, on ne gagne pas en
indépendance euh on a toujours
besoin d'un fournisseur
étranger. Mais euh on gagne en
confort on gagne en confort et
on gagne en quantité. Alors en
ce qui concerne le cuivre, euh
si mes derniers chiffres sont
exacts, parce que il y avait un
document de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie qui
donnait ça. Il me semble que le
rapport entre euh le solaire et
le nucléaire, c'est de l'ordre
de grandeur, c'est plus hein
sur le la quantité de cuivre
par kilowatter produit. Donc
dans un cas comme dans l'autre,
si on veut faire du décarboné,
on a on est moins dépendant.
Euh si on fait du nucléaire que
si on fait un système solaire,
euh et d'une manière générale,
les énergies renouvelables qui
exploitent des sources
diffuses, donc le vent et le
soleil, ont besoin de plus de
collecteurs pour avoir la même
quantité d'énergie à l'arrivée,
sans parler du fait qu'en plus
euh il faut concentrer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans une
civilisation de la puissance,
donc on a besoin de sources
concentrées. Euh il faut enfin
si on veut maintenir un système
qui est pas trop éloigné du
système actuel, d'après on peut
débattre d'autres choses. il
faut concentrer et il faut
éventuellement stocker euh,
parce que les hydrocarbures
assurent également la fonction
de stock euh, j'ai envie de
dire par construction. Tout ça
demande également des moyens
supplémentaires euh, et donc de
à chaque fois des métaux euh,
en plus. Donc, stricto sensu
euh, développer la filière
nucléaire je le je le répète
euh, c'est pas être indépendant
puisqu'on a toujours besoin de
fournisseurs de métaux
étrangers, c'est moins
dépendant au niveau des métaux
que d'autres options dans les
dans les trois choses que vous
avez citées, alors il y en a
une qu'on peut exclure tout de
suite, c'est la fusion, euh la
fusion, mes enfants seront
morts, que ça sera toujours pas
quelque chose qui va changer la
donne euh de façon
significative dans
l'approvisionnement électrique
décarboné. Je voudrais quand
même rappeler que Iter
aujourd'hui, c'est un
dispositif qui a seulement pour
objet euh de produire un peu
plus d'énergie avec la fusion
du plasma, que l'énergie qui a
été nécessaire pour mettre le
placement au chauffe à quelques
millions de degrés. Par
ailleurs, Iter ne comporte
aucun dispositif électrogène et
je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui
on sait faire un dispositif
électrogène avec du rayonnement
gamin et des neutrons, puisque
c'est essentiellement ça qu'on
d'un réacteur euh à fusion euh
alors que dans un réacteur
affiché, on récupère de l'eau
chaude, c'est quand même un peu
plus simple. Donc le, voilà,
donc Iterre euh, on oublie euh,
ça va pas changer grand-chose
avant que les gens dans cette
salle ne passent de vie à
Trépa. En ce qui concerne la
quatrième génération, pour moi,
c'est le gros déterminant du
fait que on ait un nucléaire
entre guillemets, durable à
l'avenir ou pas. Euh, le
nucléaire qu'on exploite
aujourd'hui exploite, comme
vous le savez, probablement, un
isotope très de l'uranium,
l'uranium deux-cent-trente-cinq
qui est présent à environ zéro
7 % dans l'uranium naturel. Les
quantités récupérables
d'uranium sur terre en ordre de
grandeur. Font que si on
voulait remplacer toujours sur
Terre, si on raisonne CO2,
hein. Euh une fraction
significative des centrales à
charbon mondiale par de
l'uranium, enfin par du
nucléaire. Il y a pas assez
d'uranium de 135 pour que ce
truc-là flotte euh pendant euh
des siècles. Hein? Euh il y en
a pas assez. Donc il faut
absolument si on veut que le
nucléaire soit durable, passer
à la quatrième génération qui
elle est capable d'exploiter
soit l'uranium de
cent-trente-huit, soit
l'utorium. Et il faut le faire
dans pas trop longtemps, parce
que pour démarrer ces réacteurs
de quatrième génération, on a
quand même besoin du seul
matériau officiel qu'on trouve
sur terre qui est l'uranium de
cent-35. Donc le jour où il y a
plus d'uranium de 135 du tout,
c'est évidemment caricatural
hein comme euh mais pour bien
faire comprendre, on ne peut
plus démarrer de réacteurs euh
de quatrième génération, c'est
plus possible. est-ce que si la
France passait à la quatrième
génération, on augmenterait
notre indépendance ? Oui, on
serait capable d'exploiter les
stocks d'uranium 238 qu'on a
accumulés, très bien, mais en
fait, ça ne change pas
grand-chose dans le panorama
d'ensemble, parce que je le
redis, euh on continue à avoir
besoin d'importer d'autres
métaux pour construire les
réacteurs, pour euh et cetera.
Et le poids de l'uranium dans
l'affaire est pas quelque chose
d'absolument euh fondamental.
c'est toujours bon à prendre.
Hein? Euh mais l'argument
premier pour passer à la
quatrième génération, il est
pas qu'on a accumulé des stocks
d'uranium de 138 en France. Il
est que euh à l'échelle
mondiale, j'ai envie de dire,
c'est le seul nucléaire qui
puisse être réellement durable.
pour continuer dans le panorama
que vous faites, vous avez
parlé des hydrocarbures, enfin
des faux cils en général, là du
nucléaire et peut-être vous
pouvez nous dresser le tableau
pour euh un certain nombre
d'énergies renouvelables, à la
fois en en capacité à sécuriser
les approvisionnements euh à
moyen terme et puis euh bien
sûr en capacité de de métaux et
de fiabilité. En ce qui
concerne les énergies
renouvelables, la France elle
est euh avec une un trio de
tête qui ressemble beaucoup à
ce qu'on a dans le monde
puisque les trois premières
énergies renouvelables dans le
monde sont alors sous réserve
de ce que j'ai dit en ouverture
sur la déforestation, d'abord
la biomasse, c'est la première
énergie qu'on utilise dans le
monde. Ensuite arrive
l'hydroélectricité euh
c'est-à-dire le l'exploitation
des fleuves et en troisième
arrive l'éolien. Et en fait en
France on a le même trio de
tête euh c'est-à-dire que la
première énergie renouvelable
en France c'est le bois. Euh la
deuxième c'est le hum
l'hydroélectricité et la
troisième maintenant c'est
l'éolien. Les perspectives pour
ces différentes énergies
renouvelables sont assez
différentes. Alors en ce qui
concerne le bois ces par euh
l'évolution de euh la forêt. Or
notre forêt, elle va être mise
à mal par le réchauffement
climatique à condition
climatique stabilisée,
c'est-à-dire si demain matin le
réchauffement s'arrêtait, on a
quand même 10% de la forêt
française qui va mourir. Dans
un monde à deux degrés on se
rapproche plutôt de 40 ou 50 %.
Des espèces actuelles hein.
Vous avez le hêtre qui
disparaît quasiment euh vous
avez une bonne partie des
chaînes qui vont disparaître,
vous avez l'épicéa qui
disparaît en plaine, une bonne
partie des sapins qui
disparaissent et cetera. Euh
donc et et et quand je dis ça,
je me réfère à des simulations
qui ont été faites avec toutes
les réserves qu'on peut avoir,
sachant que ces dernières
années, euh ce qui s'est
vraiment passé en France est
allé plutôt plus vite euh du
mauvais côté de la barrière que
les simulations dont j'avais
connaissance il y a dix ans,
hein, donc euh c'est voilà,
malheureusement le le j'ai j'ai
envie de dire le l'évolution
elle est plutôt plus
désagréable euh que l'idée
qu'on pouvait s'en faire. Et si
on commence à avoir un
dépérissement forestier
généralisé, ben euh avoir euh
enfin oui on aura les arbres
morts mais après on aura plus
rien quoi. Donc ça ça c'est
quelque chose qui est voilà il
y a cette hypothèque-là euh sur
l'approvisionnement en
biomasse. En ce qui concerne
l'hydroélectricité on va avoir
un stress euh hydrique là aussi
qui va nous desservir euh
puisque globalement les
simulations en ce qui concerne
le réchauffement climatique
montre un assèchement sur le
pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen dont les Alpes au
sens large font partie hein
enfin le en particulier la la
partie sud Donc il va y avoir
un sujet euh et en fait ça peut
remonter même assez au nord
puisque cette année, je sais
pas si vous avez vu passer
cette information, mais la
Norvège euh a des réservoirs de
barrages qui sont très mal
remplis. Donc la la sécheresse
est allée suffisamment au nord
en Europe pour que la Norvège
évoque même la possibilité
d'exporter moins d'électricité
que d'habitude, ce qui a fait
hurler le Danemark euh qui a
besoin euh des échanges avec la
Norvège pour équilibrer
l'intermittence de son parc
éolien euh extrêmement
développé. Donc euh
l'hydroélectricité est un voilà
il y a il y a il y a un sujet
et on peut pas tellement la
développer beaucoup plus en
France, alors on peut faire de
la micro-hydraulique mais le
dictionnaire est bien fait,
micro-hydraulique, ça fait des
micro-productions donc euh même
si on fait beaucoup de
micro-productions, à l'arrivée
ça fait pas quelque chose qui
va changer significativement la
donne euh à l'échelle
française. C'est toujours bon à
prendre là où on là où on peut
le faire euh sans engendrer de
nuisances écologiques euh
éventuellement euh remettre des
mettre des alternateurs sur
cette en haut de moulin et
cetera mais ça va pas faire des
volumes considérables. Ah
arrivent les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables alors arrivent
deux deux contributions en
particulier, les pompes à
chaleur et euh l'éolien. En ce
qui concerne l'éolien, c'est
très simple hein, on compte
l'énergie électrique qui sort
d'une éolienne quand euh les
pales sont mises en mouvement
par la force du vent. La limite
euh les les alors l'avantage de
l'éolien c'est qu'effectivement
une fois construite, l'éolienne
n'engendre pas d'émission, Les
limites sont que, comme ça
exploite une énergie
relativement diffuse, parce que
l'air c'est pas très dense. euh
voilà donc dans eux également
mis de MV2 donc dans un mètre
cube d'air en mouvement il y a
pas beaucoup d'énergie
cinétique et donc il faut
construire beaucoup d'éoliennes
pour récupérer des quantités
significatives d'électricité ça
veut dire avoir beaucoup de
projets et donc à ce moment il
y a beaucoup d'endroits où il y
a des gens qui sont
éventuellement capables de
discuter alors on peut soit
leur dire vous discutez pas euh
soit discutez les deux options
des avantages et des
inconvénients et ensuite le
vent euh n'est pas toujours
régulier en permanence et une
éolienne, il faut savoir que sa
puissance dépend du cube du
vent. Donc si vous divisez la
vitesse du vent par deux, la
puissance électrique fournie
est divisée par huit. Ce qui
veut dire que et quand vous
regardez à l'échelle de
l'Europe, même avec
l'interconnexion de toutes les
éoliennes européennes,
l'ensemble du parc éoliens
européen peut descendre à deux
rarement, mais il y a quelques
moments dans l'année où il
descend à moins de 5% de la
puissance installée pour
l'ensemble de l'Europe, hein.
Donc on ne peut pas avoir un
système qui est purement
éolien, et même en rajoutant du
solaire, qui est un peu contrac
par rapport à l'éolien, parce
que vous avez plutôt de
l'éolien euh l'hiver. Quand il
y a peu de soleil et du soleil,
l'été, quand il y a peu de
vent, donc euh vous avez deux
deux systèmes contractes, enfin
un peu contractes, l'ensemble
des deux ne permet quand
toujours pas d'avoir un
approvisionnement garanti. Donc
quand on donc ces ces donc ces
énergies-là elles ont comme
limite une limite en
emplacement, faut avoir
beaucoup d'emplacements et une
limite en matériaux, c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure
puisque elles sont beaucoup
plus intensives en métal euh
que les modes centralisés euh
que nous avons l'habitude
d'utiliser jusqu'à maintenant.
Donc des limites qui sont
plutôt physiques. À contrario
des limites du nucléaire qui
sont plutôt des des limites de
compétences? Et et et de
consensus j'ai envie de dire.
La limite côté nucléaire elle
est plus du côté de la volonté
humaine. La limite côté
nouvelles énergies
renouvelables, elle est plus du
côté des barrières physiques.
Hein si je si je voilà. Je suis
pas en train de dire que la
volonté humaine c'est une
limite qui est plus simple à
franchir hein. Peut-être pas
dire ce que j'ai pas dit. Euh
elle peut être beaucoup plus
compliquée mais euh voilà. les
pompes à chaleur euh, ça
exploite le transfert d'énergie
entre l'environnement et
l'intérieur d'un logement ou
l'intérieur d'une usine parce
qu'on peut faire des pompes à
chaleur haute température pour
euh les procédés industriels,
pour faire de la vapeur
industrielle. Avec un cycle
thermodynamique qui se trouve à
voir en général l'avantage
d'avoir un rendement supérieur
à un, c'est-à-dire que pour un
kilowattheure d'électricité que
vous injectez dans la machine,
vous transférez plusieurs
kilowatts heures de chaleur
entre l'extérieur et
l'intérieur d'un logement.
C'est une aujourd'hui qui
commence à devenir
significative, mais c'est une
énergie renouvelable, c'est un
peu un un paradoxe qui a besoin
d'électricité pour être mise en
oeuvre. Hein, euh et donc quand
j'avais fait un petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur, euh si on
voulait remplacer l'ensemble du
chauffage au gaz dans ce pays
par des pompes à chaleur, après
avoir préalablement isolé
l'ensemble des bâtiments, euh
on en a quand même pour
quelques dizaines de térawatts
d'électricité à trouver. On
peut les trouver? Enfin, on
peut les trouver, on peut
décider de les faire, mais
voilà, c'est pas quelque chose
quand même qu'on va trouver
sous le pied d'un cheval. après
arrivent des contributions qui
sont plus mineures euh dans
lesquelles on va trouver les
agrocarburants, on va trouver
le solaire, euh on va trouver
la géothermie, voilà, on va
trouver des choses comme ça euh
qui qui sont qui sont plus
marginales.
Il y
a aucune de ces énergies
renouvelables pour lesquelles
on puisse se dire quand on
regarde bien il y a pas de
problème à leur expansion
indéfinie.
Voilà, c'est c'est c'est ça le
problème.
Une dernière euh question,
enfin un paquet de questions
euh pour ma part qui a plus
très euh à votre expérience et
votre participation au débat
public depuis de de nombreuses
années euh le le discours sur
les énergies euh nucléaires,
sur la production d'énergie
nucléaire en France a beaucoup
varié euh ben si on prend une
borne arbitraire euh des années
80 euh à aujourd'hui euh euh de
la préparation à la fermeture
de super phénix, des décisions
prises dans les années 2000
jusqu'à la fermeture de la
centrale de Fessenheim jusqu'au
jusqu'au discours du président
de la République de Belfort, en
tant que au débat public euh à
la fois avec les les décideurs
politiques mais aussi euh dans
les universités, dans le débat
public, quel regard vous portez
sur toutes ces évolutions et et
à quelle cause, quelle cause
vous lui êtes vouloir
attribuer?
je me méfie beaucoup de en ce
qui me concerne du fait que je
vois à midi à ma porte comme
beaucoup de gens euh quand on
regarde les sondages sur les
Français et l'énergie en fait
on se rend compte que euh ce
qui va beaucoup compter, c'est
le prix. et après il y a
beaucoup d'autres trucs qui
comptent quand même beaucoup
moins. Je je
Ce que je constate quand même
c'est que les systèmes
énergétique y vivent sur un pas
de temps qui n'est pas celui
euh de la démocratie euh donc
en gros euh les le le gros
problème des débats sur
l'énergie c'est que ils portent
toujours sur des pas de temps
qui sont un ordre de grandeur
en dessous euh de ce qu'il
faudrait regarder. on
s'intéresse à ce qu'on va faire
dans les années qui viennent
euh alors qu'il faudrait que on
ait quelque chose d'un peu
construit sur les décennies qui
viennent et qu'on n'y revienne
pas tous les quatre matins.
Donc en fait il faut arriver à
créer un consensus dans la
population parce que il y a que
le consensus dans la population
qui transcende les alternances
électorales sur la façon dont
il faut s'organiser et ensuite
qu'on en dévie pas trop en
espérant que la premier le
premier jet que le coup d'essai
soit un coup de mètre,
c'est-à-dire que le premier jet
et la première copie qu'on rend
soit la bonne. Parce que quand
on a euh quand on est dans une
course contre la montre, ce qui
est notre cas hein, à la fois
avec le changement climatique
et avec l'épuisement de ce qui
a fait euh, la civilisation
moderne, on va pas avoir droit
à essai erreur cinquante fois
hein, c'est absolument évident.
Et en fait on va déjà payer le
prix d'une partie des essais
erreurs qu'on a faits dans le
passé. j'ai je je ne suis pas
en mesure de savoir moi-même
euh comment expliquer très
exactement ce qui s'est passé
sur les vingt dernières années.
Donc euh je continue à
fouiller, à essayer de me de me
construire une histoire, euh je
suis pas au bout de ma quête
donc je ne sais pas pourquoi,
est-ce qu'il y a eu un certain
il y a il y a des épisodes
isolés qu'on est capables de de
de reproduire. Euh par exemple
il fait absolument aucun doute
dans mon esprit euh que la
partie 50 % de nucléaires et
fermetures de Fessenheim, c'est
Hollande qui voulait un accord
avec les Verts, euh donc ça je
suis capable de le
caractériser, de le dater et
cetera, c'est un voilà. Mais il
y a il et euh c'était
exactement pareil en ce qui
concerne euh Jospin et Super
Phénix. Mais par contre euh il
y a d'autres trucs pour
lesquels je suis c'est très
difficile pour moi euh
d'essayer d'expliquer dans dans
dans son ensemble. Un truc par
exemple que je suis pas capable
d'expliquer c'est pourquoi
est-ce que le pétrole est si
absent du débat public en
France? Euh le pic de
production du pétrole, tout le
monde s'en fout, euh je redis
qu'en cochet avait organisé son
colloque ici, ça avait fait
rigoler tout le monde. Et
encore aujourd'hui, quand vous
expliquez qu'on est déjà
rentrés en décrue subi
d'approvisionnement pétrolier,
les gens vous regardent avec
des yeux comme des soucoupes.
Ils en entendent jamais parler
euh et cetera. on a un peu
commencé à parler du gaz depuis
que monsieur Poutine nous fait
des misères mais enfin euh si
nous avons euh on en parlait
pas trop. Euh donc voilà donc
il y a il y a il y a une
focalisation sur l'électricité
dans le débat public euh qui ne
vous aura pas échappé. Euh et
en particulier sur un
antagonisme nucléaire euh
nucléaire renouvelable euh
renouvelable électrique, je
précise, puisqu'encore une
fois, la première renouvelable
en France, c'est le bois, qui
est pas électrique. Euh qui qui
fait les choux gras de la
presse et euh qui nous, qui
nous occupent beaucoup. Mais je
il il y a des questions pour
lesquelles j'ai toujours pas de
réponse. Je ne sais toujours
pas pourquoi est-ce que le
débat public s'est structuré
avec euh en se focalisant sur
certains points, pourquoi
est-ce que il y a des décisions
à certains moments qui ont été
prises euh enfin voilà je je
j'ai pas j'ai j'ai j'ai pas
encore les idées totalement
claires sur le sujet, même moi.
pardon et toute dernière alors
parce que vous vous y incitez
sur le niveau d'information euh
de la population du grand
public, des décideurs publics
au sens large euh euh en termes
de de connaissances du du
domaine énergétique et et
l'implication sur les décisions
prises. il est faible euh c'est
pas un sujet central dans
l'information médiatique alors
c'est pas un sujet central dans
la formation médiatique
probablement parce que euh
c'est vu comme un bien de
consommation avant d'être vu
comme le déterminant de ce qui
fait notre monde hein euh
l'énergie je le redis on en
parle euh euh les carburants on
on en parle parce qu'on les
achète pas que sans camion, il
y aurait pas de ville. Mais
sans camion il y a pas de ville
hein, pas de parce que vous
avez pas à manger, vous avez
pas de bien de consommation,
vous avez rien quoi, pas de
ville sans camion. Donc on on
ne on ne parle de l'énergie que
sous l'angle du prix, ce qui
est quand même extrêmement
réducteur et ce qui est très
court-termiste. d'une façon
générale dans les médias
français euh il y a quand même
un il y a il y a il y a un
problème de qualification
technique euh j'ai envie de
dire. Alors qui se qui évolue
doucement hein. Euh mais les
sujets très techniques sont
toujours des sujets avec
lesquels les médias français
sont pas très à l'aise. Euh
peut-être que ça tient la
formation des journalistes qui
n'est pas technique donc du
coup euh il faut qu'il compense
par de l'expérience sur le tas
pour y arriver et euh ça prend
du temps. Euh peut-être que
c'est dû à l'organisation des
rédactions euh ou euh la c'est
le c'est le service politique
euh qui justement ne discute
pas des vices et des boulons
parce que l'intendance suivra,
enfin je sais pas, il y a il y
a il y a mais il y a une il y a
une euh c'est clair que la
qualité euh de l'information
elle est pas terrible et le
niveau d'information de la
population n'est pas très
élevé. La bonne question c'est
est-ce que c'est très différent
dans les autres pays
occidentaux? Euh j'ai pas la
réponse à cette question. Euh
je je serais étonné que ce soit
monstrueusement différent dans
l'essentiel des pays
occidentaux euh on va dire. Je
pense qu'il y a quelques pays
qui sont quand même un peu plus
matures euh je pense que la
Grande-Bretagne euh est un pays
dans lequel le débat est un peu
plus éclairé un peu.
mais mais
d'une manière
générale, le le degré de
compréhension du grand public
et son degré d'implication euh
dans dans ces débats est très
faible. Quand on dit qu'on fait
des débats publics, il faut
bien voir que ça concerne une
toute petite fraction de la
population. Euh si je prends
par exemple les débats là qui
sont organisés en ce moment par
la CNDP euh c'est des débats
euh je je serai curieux de voir
à la fin du débat quelle est la
fraction de la population qui
aura entendu parler du débat?
voilà mon expérience c'est que
c'est toujours des débats qui
concernent une toute petite
fraction de la population.
Alors c'est pas nécessairement
une bonne nouvelle mais en tout
cas c'est une donnée du
problème. En ce qui concerne
les décideurs et les élus euh
alors là j'ai envie de dire que
la situation s'est différenciée
sur les dix dernières années.
Je pense que euh le monde civil
a progressé plus vite que le
monde politique. quand je vois
les débats qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui dans le monde
politique sur ce sujet, j'ai
pas l'impression qu'on ait
beaucoup bougé par rapport à il
y a dix ans. Euh quand je vois
le il y a des décisions qui
peuvent être prises, mais je
veux dire globalement, je
trouve que on n'a pas on n'a
pas ou il y a vingt ans. Euh
quand euh dans le dans le monde
dans la société civile, euh la
conscience que les temps qui
s'annoncent risquent pas être
très simples
La compréhension d'un certain
nombre de choses en ce qui
concerne et je parle là plutôt
des décideurs euh en ce qui
concerne à la fois le climat et
l'énergie a quand même un peu
progressé.
Voilà. Alors on va passer aux
questions des groupes. Alors
euh pour Renaissance est-ce
qu'il y a quelqu'un? Non. pour
le RN, est-ce que quelqu'un a
une question? Monsieur Tanguy?
Allez-y. Oui merci monsieur le
président, bonjour monsieur
Lancovici. Écoutez j'ai j'ai
écouté j'ai pas pu être là euh
il y avait le quarante-neuf
trois donc j'ai pas entendu
votre euh euh introduction euh
j'ai j'ai entendu vos vos
réponses aux questions. Je vais
me fonder sur euh les travaux
que j'ai lu de vous et les les
nombreux interviews que j'avais
entendus de vous notamment
rebondir sur ce que vous avez
sur le pétrole. Bon alors un
autre modèle modeste échelle
effectivement nous aussi on
essaie de mettre le sujet du
pétrole depuis plus de 10 ans
dans le débat public. Nous
avons euh échoué. Même là en ce
moment vous avez du gaz avec
Poutine, le pétrole, le fait
même dans le dans les
ressources financières de la
Russie sont plus importantes
que les, que les ressources
financières liées au gaz et
pourtant même ça ça a échoué.
Bon, ça reste euh, on le voit
bien aujourd'hui dans les
préoccupations des Français, on
l'a encore vu avec la pénurie
euh, qu'on qu'on qu'on a subi
reste euh, reste un sujet
central et pourtant euh,
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
solution technique donc
j'espère enfin l'une des
raisons de cette commission
j'espère c'est pas seulement de
de critiquer pour critiquer
même sinon on s'en sortirait
bien c'est de de de savoir ce
qu'on fait voilà bon euh, et
bien entendu vos vos réflexions
sur les moyens de production
euh, électriques euh,
électrogènes euh, alternatifs
mais euh, comment on fait?
Voilà, qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour le pétrole et pour
remplacer cette ce don euh, ce
ce ce don de la nature enfin ce
don euh, empoisonné mais enfin
en tout cas techniquement euh,
ce don qui a permis euh, à la
société de consommation et
aussi euh, l'amélioration des
conditions euh, de de du plus
grand nombre parce que bon je
pour vous suivre euh,
régulièrement et le le
l'impasse la pourrie qu'on a
dans le débat public c'est euh,
le lien que entre la hausse du
niveau de vie et la démocratie
est quand même évident. Euh
donc tout le monde remet en
cause visiblement euh le
l'abaissement du niveau de vie
comme une une fatalité. Moi ce
qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est
que je pense que ce sera lié à
une baisse euh de la de du
niveau de démocratie des
libertés publiques qui va avec
Donc le la la la l'importance
de trouver une solution à ce
qui est permis non pas à
l'enrichissement des personnes
mais juste que leur vie soit
plus douce, plus agréable et
plus vivable euh nous préoccupe
vivement donc vous avez fait
beaucoup de critiques et je les
entends hein, c'est pas une
critique de la critique, mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire?
Vous, à votre place, qu'est-ce
que vous prendrez comme options
techniques, sachant le panel de
technologiques, mais la France.
la réponse elle est alors la
réponse longue elle figure dans
les travaux qui ont été faits
par le chiffre Project euh sur
la façon de faire évoluer le
parc de bâtiments et la
mobilité quand on regarde où
sont les usages du pétrole en
France aujourd'hui, en fait on
a trois grandes euh on a trois
grands usages en fin trois
usages importants on va dire,
il y a un usage dans la
mobilité euh l'essentiel du
pétrole va dans la mobilité des
marchandises et dans la
mobilité des personnes et
paradoxalement on est plus
dépendant encore de la mobilité
des marchandises qui n'ont pas
de jambes, que de la mobilité
des personnes. Euh il y avait
il y a longtemps, j'avais fait
remarquer que si demain matin
il y avait une voiture sur
trois seulement qui était
capable de rouler en France euh
eh bien tout le monde
gueulerait euh mais en
attendant on arriverait à
s'organiser quand même. Alors
que si demain matin il y a
seulement un camion sur trois
qui roule en France, on a un
tout petit sujet
d'approvisionnement
alimentaire. Donc euh la il y a
30 % des camions en France qui
transportent un truc qui se
mange. Donc le donc ce le le le
pétrole il sert euh d'abord à
ça, il sert ensuite un peu au
chauffage et enfin il sert un
peu dans l'industrie et dans
l'industrie, son usage le plus
précieux et comme matière
première euh pour faire de la
chimie organique euh laquelle
chimie organique va se
retrouver absolument partout
euh dans les vêtements, dans
les bâtiments, dans les
détergents euh dans et et et
dans euh j'ai envie de dire les
biens intermédiaires qui
servent à toute l'industrie à
Laval. Les options pour
remplacer le pétrole euh sont
pas les mêmes en fonction de ce
qu'on regarde. Alors en ce qui
concerne la mobilité euh au
chiffre Project on a fait un
certain nombre il y a un
certain nombre de morceaux du
plan de transformation de
l'économ qui porte là-dessus.
On a à la fois euh analyser la
mobilité longue distance, euh
la euh dont la mobilité
aérienne a fait l'objet d'un
rapport à part, euh la mobilité
du quotidien, la mobilité des
marchandises. Donc on a regardé
tout ça. Si je fais cours dans
les conclusions, il va falloir
faire avec moins de voitures
euh parce que euh l'énergie
c'est un demi de MV2, donc
quand on déplace une virgule 5
tonnes de métal, ben euh ma
foi, on a besoin d'une certaine
quantité d'énergie, et si on
n'a plus le pétrole, les
énergies alternatives, que ce
soit l'électrification, les
agrocarburant et cetera euh ne
permettront pas de conserver en
France 40 millions de véhicules
particuliers comme on les a
aujourd'hui. C'est pas
nécessairement un drame euh
simplement il faut pouvoir
s'organiser en conséquence. Non
c'est pas nécessairement un
drame et de toute façon on va
devoir faire avec. Donc euh je
confère ce que j'ai dit euh
tout à l'heure à la question
sur la croissance. Donc après
on peut taper du pied et se
rouler par terre mais ça
changera strictement rien. Donc
euh
Ça c'est votre métier euh, si
vous me le si vous le prenez
comme ça hein. Euh, donc je je
je le redis euh, moi je suis là
pour vous faire part de faits
physiques, l'effet physique
c'est qu'on va en avoir moins
et que avec moins on aura moins
de voitures. Alors après euh,
on peut s'organiser encore une
fois euh, en faisant en sorte
que ce soit pas un drame euh,
où on peut ne rien faire et si
on ne fait rien à ce moment ce
sera un drame, c'est ça qui va
se passer en fait, c'est-à-dire
que les au fur et à mesure que
on sera privés bah, il y a des
gens qui vont être sortis du
jeu sans avoir vu le coup venir
à l'avance, c'est exactement ça
qui va se passer. Euh, si
s'organiser pour pas que ce
soit un drame, euh ça veut dire
que il faut qu'on développe
dans ce pays euh des transports
en commun pas nécessairement
des transports lourds, le reste
euh il faut faire aussi des bus
et des autocars. Euh il faut
faire du covoiturage, euh il
faut faire des modes actifs euh
alors qu'ils sont
particulièrement pertinents en
ville et en et en périphérie de
ville danse, c'est évidemment
beaucoup moins euh facile de se
balader à vélo sur 30 bornes
quand on est euh loin de tout.
Euh pardon? C'est voilà. Euh
oui mais il y a plein
d'endroits où on est pas loin
de tout. Euh donc euh il y a
plein d'endroits où on peut
quand même s'organiser pour
faire autrement hein. Euh et il
va falloir également euh
s'occuper du transport des
marchandises et là c'est
exactement pareil. Euh il y a
une partie du fret qu'on peut
électrifier sur autoroute euh
ou sur grands axes en en en
hybridant les camions et en les
électrifiants, il y a une
partie du fret qu'on peut
basculer sur le ferroviaire. Il
y a une partie du fret qu'il
faut arrêter de déplacer. Euh
je pense pas aujourd'hui que si
aujourd'hui on arrêtait les
livraisons sous 24 heures euh
par un GAFA que je ne nommerai
pas, je sais pas si la
population se suiciderait. Je
suis pas complètement persuadé.
Euh donc il y a nombre de
choses, on peut tout simplement
y renoncer sans que ce soit
dramatique. Euh ce qui va être
ennuyeux c'est pour les gens
qui y travaillent. Donc en fait
si on doit renoncer à une
activité, la vraie question
c'est pas tant le drame pour le
consommateur parce que il y a
un certain nombre de choses
pour lesquelles je pense qu'on
y arrivera encore à peu près.
C'est euh le drame pour les
gens qui y travaillent. Donc en
fait il faut planifier ce genre
de truc et il faut se le faire
avec un préavis suffisant pour
que euh les gens puissent
trouver quelque chose qui les
intéresse ailleurs. En ce qui
concerne le transport aérien,
le transport aérien est né avec
le pétrole et mourra avec le
pétrole. Euh là quand regarde
les alternatives
technologiques, il y en a pas
une qui est à l'échelle de
façon raisonnable. Euh si on
devait, je vais juste vous
donner un exemple sur les
agrocarburants. Le pétrole
aujourd'hui consomme 8% du
pétrole mondial. Euh l'avion
pardon euh consomme 8% du
pétrole mondial. Si je
transformais en agrocaburant
les quatre premières cultures
végétales dans le monde, qui
sont le maïs, le riz, euh le
blé et le soja intégralement en
agrocaburant, intégralement en
agrocaburant. Euh j'aurais en
gros un quart du pétrole
mondial. C'est-à-dire que
j'aurai trois fois ce que
consomme l'aérien. Donc on
oublie les agrocarburants euh
pour promener des riches en
avion. On oublie quoi. Euh donc
le le donc une partie du
transport aérien va va va se
contracter voilà c'est on va
faire avec mais c'est pas
nécessairement un drame. Euh
voilà on fera autrement. Et ces
choses-là encore une fois moins
on les anticipe et plus ça sera
désagréable. Donc la
technologie elle va nous
permettre d'amortir un certain
nombre euh de d'évolutions.
Elle va nous permettre trouver
d'autres choses, un vélo
électrique c'est un objet
technologique. C'est un objet
technologique. Vous avez
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'équipementiers en France qui
ont commencé à se mettre euh à
euh des des pièces euh pour les
vélos électriques. Si on passe
de voitures importées à des
vélos électriques fabriqués en
France, on peut à la fois avoir
de la sobriété dans les
déplacements et gagner en
emploi. En France, hein. Donc
il faut pas voir nécessairement
euh le changement de mode de
déplacement comme quelque chose
nécessairement dramatique à
chaque fois il y a des choses
intéressantes et des choses qui
y sont moins et il faut essayer
de faire le tri de telle sorte
que l'option soit la plus
intéressante possible. Mais de
toute façon les limites de
l'exercice, je le redis, c'est
que du pétrole on va en avoir
de moins en moins et que c'est
un truc qui est tellement
extraordinaire euh en termes
physiques euh j'ai envie de
dire hein euh que euh les
options pour le remplacer on en
aura pas à l'échelle. Voilà
c'est comme ça. Mais encore une
fois je suis pas sûr que ce
soit très grave. Si on
s'organise bien. Euh pardon,
j'ai pas couvert les bâtiments,
les bâtiments il faut remplacer
le les chaudières à fioul par
des pompes à chaleur en ayant
isolé les bâtiments, voilà. Et
à ce moment on tombe sur des
problèmes pratiques qui sont
euh avoir suffisamment
d'artisans, avoir suffisamment
de pompes à chaleur fabriqués
en France et avoir une
production électrique
suffisante. Voilà c'est on
tombe sur les problèmes
pratiques de cette nature. Euh
alors euh ce que je vous
propose on va on va essayer de
prendre euh des séries de de
trois questions parce que sinon
on arrivera pas à à tenir le le
timing et je reprends l'ordre
des groupes donc euh madame
Manier Millefort. Wilferd
pardon. Ça va venir hein, on
sera ensemble pendant 6 mois.
Merci Monsieur le Président,
pas d'inquiétude. Euh merci
monsieur Jancovici alors moi
j'ai une question euh sur euh
les besoins de chaleur en
France, ça représente je crois
50% à peu près de l'énergie
qu'on consomme en France,
l'énergie finale euh pourquoi
euh est-ce que les sujets des
ENR thermiques sont si mal
investis en France, vous avez
évoqué le prisme électrique
mais enfin il y a il y a
peut-être pas que ça donc
pourquoi est-ce que ça bloque
autant? Deuxième question euh
euh sur les l'évolution des
consommations euh énergétique
on a tendance à voir que plus
on augmente la production, plus
on augmente les consommations,
est-ce quà un il est possible
de de revenir en arrière sur un
certain nombre de technologies
euh inflationnistes et
énergétique pour retrouver euh
euh finalement des euh des des
des consommations qui pour
répondre à peu près aux mêmes
usages, je consomme moins
d'énergie, on voit par exemple
les véhicules euh euh ils
viennent de plus en plus gros,
de plus de plus en plus
importants, finalement euh ils
servent le même usage quand ils
sont finalement plus petits,
moins moins lourds euh et ils
font le même usage euh euh
service rendu. Donc est-ce
qu'on peut revenir aux usages
pour pour poser la question du
besoin énergétique en France et
du coup poser la la question de
la sobriété euh euh de cette et
ma dernière question c'est euh
vous avez parlé du consensus
euh, qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
créer dans la population sur
une stratégie énergétique
globale qui dépasserait euh,
les alternances politiques mais
en l'occurrence euh, la les
grandes oppositions euh, de
dissensus qu'on a pu avoir
c'était celle des ENR et du
nucléaire pendant longtemps et
pour le coup vous y avez un peu
contribué à créer du dissensus
donc comment est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on dépasse ce
dissensus et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez réglé
vos distenus avec les EMR?
Alors Monsieur pardon
on va prendre plusieurs
questions monsieur ouais alors
Alors il y avait la chaleur la
sobriété et le consensus
Alors attendez, on va vous
trouver ça.
Voilà, du coup monsieur euh
monsieur Merci Monsieur le
Président. J'attendais que
monsieur Jancovici ait terminé
parce que j'ai un certain
nombre de questions.
Merci euh merci à vous déjà
pour euh l'exposé, les
premières réponses aux
questions. Je partage avec vous
euh des objectifs euh assez
ambitieux euh de sobriété, je
crois qu'on s'en sortira pas
euh si on fixe pas des
objectifs et si on
effectivement on n'arrive pas à
les discuter avec les gens euh
la sobriété doit faire aussi
euh l'objet de de consensus
dans la population. Bon un
certain nombre de questions
assez précises euh sur le
nucléaire et sur les
renouvelables pour finir, sur
le nucléaire. On a le parc
nucléaire actuellement
confronté à un au problème des
corrosions sont contraintes,
est-ce que vous avez euh des
indications euh techniques sur
le sujet, la possibilité de les
surmonter. Sur les EPR, alors
vous
avez parlé des des euh des
centrales de quatrième
génération mais actuellement ce
qui est euh euh en projet c'est
les EPR deux, on a euh le
problème de Flamandville qui
est toujours pas mis en service
et qui doit être mis en service
en 20vingt-trois, mais euh je
sais plus quel est le terme
mais de manière euh en mode
dégradé, voilà. Et sur les EPR
deux euh ailleurs dans le
monde, à Taichon euh par
exemple. Euh on a entendu
parler des SMR, est-ce qu'elle
est votre avis là-dessus? Il me
semble que le nucléaire pose
aussi un problème de délai
parce que euh entre le moment
où on prend la décision,
ensuite la en fait, est-ce que
c'est vraiment raisonnable de
parier là-dessus pour euh
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique? Euh question
suivante c'est euh vous avez
euh évoqué le problème de
sécheresse et euh et du déficit
d'eau et du réchauffement de
l'eau, c'est c'est un souci
pour refroidir euh les
réacteurs, quel est votre avis
là-dessus? La question du coût
du nucléaire aussi parce que je
pense qu'il est pas euh à
l'heure actuelle, il est pas
payé euh à son à son prix réel
euh EDF est est endetté à
hauteur de 60 milliards, si on
investit dans le nucléaire,
est-ce qu'il va rester de
l'argent euh pour investir dans
dans les ENR. Euh septième
question sur la question des
déchets nucléaires qui est
quand même pas une petite
question qu'on peut balayer
d'un d'un revers de main. Et
pour terminer euh puisque il y
a quand même une un sujet qui
est le le pilotable euh dans
les énergies renouvelables on a
le biogaz et on a l'hydrogène.
Alors l'hydrogène qu'il faut
d'abord produire euh
effectivement avec de
l'électricité mais voilà quel
est votre avis euh là-dessus.
Merci. du coup que vu la masse
de questions on va vous laisser
répondre et puis on reprendra
le cycle des questions après.
Il y a un plateau repas qui est
prévu donc.
Alors euh pourquoi est-ce qu'on
parle peu de la chaleur dans ce
pays? Euh je vais tenter une
hypothèse. Euh mon hypothèse
elle elle est liée au grenelle
Au moment où euh a eu lieu le
Grenelle de l'environnement,
Sarkozy avait dit euh on ne
parlera pas de nucléaire. Du
coup, les associations euh
anti-nucléaires n'ont pas parlé
de nucléaire mais quand elles
ont parlé de renouvelable,
elles ont essentiellement parlé
de renouvelable électrique
puisque euh quand on est
anti-nucléaire, on est
essentiellement intéressé par
les renouvelables électriques.
Et donc je il y a eu un gros
accent qui a été mis dessus à
l'époque euh et la et le sujet
épatant le climat puisque
remplacer une énergie bas
carbone par une autre énergie
bas carbone ça change pas grand
chose du point de vue du climat
euh, à ce moment l'accent était
euh, sans le dire mais quand
même euh, une motivation
anti-nucléaire donc je je moi
j'ai envie de le j'ai envie de
le et et ça s'inscrit dans une
opposition euh, du reste ça
sera votre troisième question
euh, qui est plus ancienne euh,
et qui était aussi ma remarque
tout à l'heure sur le débat
public en disant que
l'opposition pour enfin le le
nucléaire et et l'élément pivot
en général des débats publics
sur l'énergie beaucoup plus que
les hydrocarbures euh et donc
ça a beaucoup structuré euh y
compris le développement des
ENR. Pour moi ça c'est ça
vient, ça vient de ça. Encore
euh aujourd'hui, alors je sais
pas bon les dernières
informations que j'avais
dataient de 2mille 8 ou
deux-mille-dix-neuf en
deux-mille-dix-huit ou
deux-mille-dix-neuf vous aviez
quand même plus de 2tiers des
Français qui pensaient que le
nucléaire contribuait
significativement aux émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et à
mon avis c'est une conséquence
directe euh de ce débat euh et
du fait que on a euh très
longtemps opposé ENR au
nucléaire euh mettre ça dans
une même famille d'énergie bas
carbone ce qui aurait
évidemment changé différemment,
sur lesquels on peut être
d'accord ou pas d'accord sur la
répartition, c'est un sujet.
Euh ce qui aurait changé la la
perception du public. C'est
alors là pour le coup c'est
très différent dans d'autres
pays européens. Euh il y a
beaucoup de d'autres pays
européens mais en général quand
la quand la chaleur
renouvelable a fait l'objet de
politiques de promotion
ancienne, c'est que le pays
avait par ailleurs un potentiel
important. Euh donc dans les
pays du nord qui ont des
gisements forestiers très
importants rapportés à la
population. La chaleur
renouvelable fait l'objet de
d'efforts depuis longtemps. Euh
quand vous en Islande euh qui a
la qui est un peu plus peuplée
que Boulogne-Billancourt, mais
pas beaucoup euh et que vous
avez le potentiel géothermique
que vous avez, ben c'est euh
pareil, il y a il y a il y a
une promotion de la chaleur
renouvelable qui est faite
depuis longtemps, il y a
probablement aussi, peut-être
qu'il y a aussi en France cet
élément qui a joué, euh
c'est-à-dire que la chaleur
renouvelable, elle avait pas un
potentiel très important, quand
elle avait un potentiel
important dans certaines
régions de France, je pense en
particulier aux DOM, euh à ce
moment, elle a fait l'objet
d'une promotion aussi puisque
les chauffe-eau solaires sont
sont raisonnablement répandues.
dans les territoires
d'outre-mer. comment est-ce que
on fait en sorte de limiter les
usages ben en le décidant? Euh
rien ne nous empêche, en
théorie, euh de militer en fin
à l'Europe puisque maintenant
c'est l'Europe qui a la
compétence, pour que on limite
le poids des véhicules neufs
vendus? C'est il y a pas de
limite physique à ça. Il y a
juste une affaire de volonté.
Il faut bien voir que quand on
augmente les usages, euh en
fait ça augmente l'activité
économique sous-jacente. Et
quand quand on a comme prisme
de lecture premier, quoi qu'on
fasse, le prisme économique, en
fait on va assez rarement
chercher à limiter les usages,
même quand il s'agit de fumer,
euh quand il s'agit de manger
euh et de boire trop sucré ou
trop gras euh et cetera, on va
pas limiter les usages. On en
fait même de la pub. Donc en
fait euh dès lors que on prend
les activités sous l'angle
économique, il y a un mécanisme
qui se met en route
naturellement, qui est de
pousser à l'inflation des
usages, parce que c'est ça qui
pousse à l'inflation de
l'activité. Donc ça veut dire
que si on veut en sortir ça
renvoie au débat qu'on a eu
tout à l'heure, il faut qu'on
accepte
euh mais ça passera par là.
Est-ce que euh je suis sorti du
dissensus? Euh j'ai toujours la
même opinion en ce qui concerne
la pertinence de remplacer du
nucléaire par des ENR, ça j'ai
toujours dit que c'était un
truc qui servait à rien et je
continue à penser que ça sert à
rien. Euh après délibérément
hein je dis bien délibérément
je pense que ça sert à rien et
que ça a été une perte de temps
et d'argent. Euh maintenant euh
est-ce que dans le cas dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est stupide de faire des ENR
non? Et ça dépend les ça dépend
pour quoi faire. Donc euh je
continue à penser qu'il faut
raisonner de manière
pragmatique et différenciée euh
et qu'il ne faut par euh ni
nucléaire ni ENR de tous les
brevets de vertus euh encore
une fois toutes les énergies
ont des avantages et des
inconvénients et euh ce que
j'espère c'est de enfin il me
semble que la bonne la bonne
situation est celle dans
laquelle on juge sur pièce.
C'est évidemment euh pas la
situation dans laquelle nous
sommes le plus souvent mais
c'est vers ça qu'il faut
essayer de tendre.
Alors. Est-ce que j'ai des
informations sur la corrosion
sous contrainte? Euh oui il y a
des informations publiques, euh
il y a Lewandowski qui a fait
une audition à l'OPEX euh pas
plus tard qu'il y a quelques
jours, dans laquelle il a
repris euh il a fait quelque
chose d'assez complet, je sais
pas si vous l'avez vu passer?
Ben allez allez voir parce que
c'est assez complet euh et en
particulier euh les
indications, il il fournit un
certain nombre euh
d'indications techniques. Euh
sur le, sur la chose. qu'est-ce
que je pense de l'EPR2 et des
SMR? Alors je pense que le PR
était un truc qui était trop
compliqué euh parce que on a
cherché à faire plaisir à la
fois aux Français et aux
Allemands parce que je vous
rappelle que c'est un réacteur
de conception euh euh
franco-allemande. Depuis
l'origine, l'ASN n'a jamais eu
à sa charge, je dis pas qu'il
faut qu'elle l'ait, mais je
rappelle juste n'a jamais eu à
sa charge de faire un arbitrage
coup bénéfice sur les mesures
de sûreté qu'elle est chargée
de mettre en oeuvre. Dit
autrement, son seul prisme de
lecture, c'est, il faut que ce
soit sûr, mais si le fait que
ce soit trop sûr, engendre un
risque de défaut
d'approvisionnement, qui
lui-même pourrait avoir des
conséquences extrêmement
délétères, c'est hors de son
mandat. C'est hors de son
champ, hein. or il me semble
que on ne pourra pas faire
l'économie euh dans un monde
qui va lui-même être en
économie de moyens, de se poser
ce genre de questions. Il me
semble quà l'avenir, on va
nécessairement être obligé de
se poser la question de savoir
jusqu'où est-ce qu'on accepte
de ne pas disposer à temps.
Mais c'est vrai pour n'importe
quoi, c'est aussi vrai pour les
éoliennes qui emmerdent un
certain nombre de gens et pour
lesquels on se dit ben il nous
enquiquine euh on va quand même
en faire parce que c'est c'est
nécessaire hein. Donc c'est
c'est vrai d'une façon plus
large. Euh on va nécessairement
être obligé de revoir
l'arbitrage euh avantages
inconvénients. À l'aune d'un
dans lequel on est un peu dans
une course contre la montre et
dans lequel on va être en
économie forcée de moyens de
façon croisière, de façon
croissante. Hein il va c'est
c'est dans ce cadre-là qu'il va
falloir raisonner, ce qui est
un cadre évidemment beaucoup
moins confortable que le cadre
dans lequel euh on raisonnait
jusqu'à maintenant, qui est un
cadre dans lequel on se dit on
a le temps et on a par ailleurs
pas d'effet d'éviction puisque
dans un monde en croissance et
où on est pas en pénurie de
moyens, on peut courir plein de
livres à la fois. Euh dans un
monde dans lequel on n'est pas
en croissance, euh si on
mauvais, c'est qu'on court pas
le bon. Et là on a un effet
d'éviction euh dont dont on
paye euh le prix euh
directement. Hein. Euh donc
dans ce monde-là, est-ce que il
faut faire un nucléaire aussi
sûr entre guillemets ou plus
exactement aussi complexe? Euh
plutôt que sur que celui qu'on
fait aujourd'hui euh c'est pas
évident. Est-ce qu'il faut
faire que des EPR2 pour
remplacer le parc actuel, je ne
le crois pas. Euh
personnellement, euh j'ai envie
de dire le le la solution qui
aurait ma préférence, c'est de
mettre le paquet sur le
développement de la quatrième
génération parce que je pense
que aujourd'hui on est à 15 ans
euh de pouvoir disposer si on
si on se met entre guillemets
en économie de guerre hein qui
est un terme que j'utilise
parfois euh on est à 15 ans de
pouvoir disposer de modèles
déployables et à ce moment on
fait la jonction avec des EPR
le temps de pouvoir commencer à
déployer de la quatrième
génération. mais on en fait pas
plus que ça. Voilà. C'est pas
une option aujourd'hui qui est
sur la table et dans
l'intervalle euh, c'est évident
que euh, aujourd'hui la seule
option qui reste donc aux
Français de décider quelque
part euh, si on veut plus
d'électricité même si elle est
pas pilotable c'est de rajouter
des moyens ENR. Dans les 10 à
15 ans qui viennent hein, il y
a il y a pas euh, il y a rien
d'autre à faire hein euh, parce
que ça va quand même plus vite
de rajouter une éolienne que de
rajouter un réacteur Ce qui
avec les ENR la difficulté est
dans le système donc elle est
pas dans l'objet faire une
éolienne c'est compliqué. Par
contre faire un système qui
repose majoritairement sur des
sources euh non pilotables, ça
c'est tellement complexe que
personnellement je pense que on
va avoir beaucoup de mal à y
arriver, hein. Euh mais on peut
en rajouter un peu, ça c'est
clair. Et par ailleurs, il y a
un scénario que j'ai trouvé
assez malin euh qui a été
publié il y a pas très
longtemps euh par une
association qui s'appelle Voie
du nucléaire dans lequel la
proposition c'est de construire
dans les décennies qui viennent
euh à la fois tant qu'on n'est
pas capable de faire la
jonction avec du nucléaire de
quatrième génération et du
nucléaire de troisième pour euh
lui-même faire la jonction. Euh
c'est de des moyens ENR et des
des steppes de construire des
steppes en France, voilà. Je
trouve que c'est c'est ça se
regarde. Euh il faudrait
regarder ça d'à peu près, je
trouve que c'est pas il y a il
y a quelque chose de séduisant
dans cette approche, alors je
l'ai pas regardé, je l'ai pas
regardé sous toutes les
coutures, je l'ai pas et
cetera, mais je trouve que
c'est quelque chose qui est pas
inintéressant et ce que eux
disent, alors ça ça vous plaira
peut-être moins mais ce que
disent c'est une fois que euh
on est capable de déployer du
nucléaire de quatrième
génération et qu'on retombe sur
des choses qui sont pilotables,
compactes et cetera, à ce
moment, les éoliennes qu'on a
construites une fois, ben on
les reconstruit pas une
deuxième, c'est-à-dire qu'une
fois qu'on en a plus besoin, au
bout de 30 ans, on les on les
déconstruit, puis s'arrête là.
Ça se regarde, je trouve que
c'est pas inintéressant euh
comme euh comme scénario. Euh
qu'est-ce que je pense des SMR?
Ben euh si c'est small, ça sera
small. Euh donc je pense que
c'est pas quelque chose qui va
euh significativement changer
la donne. Euh en fait ça peut
être très intéressant pour les
régions insulaires euh qui
aujourd'hui dépendent de
l'électricité au fioul ou de
l'électricité au charbon, donc
euh ça peut être intéressant
pour eux.
alors après euh il y avait tout
un tas de trucs sur le
nucléaire allez les délais bon
je pense que j'ai répondu hein
euh voilà sécheresse euh c'est
un problème de production,
c'est pas un problème de sûreté
euh en fait euh comme vous le
savez probablement quand on met
un réacteur à l'arrêt parce que
euh pour Dieu c'est quelle
raison hein euh vous avez
besoin pour le maintenir en
condition froide d'un millième
de l'eau dont vous avez besoin
en fonctionnement normal. Donc
si jamais vous avez plus assez
d'eau ben le risque que vous
courez c'est le défaut de
production mais vous courez un
risque de pour la sûreté, alors
le risque pour, en défaut de
production il existe pour tous
les modes qui dépendent de
l'eau. Donc il existe pour les
centrales nucléaires, il existe
pour les centrales thermiques,
alors accessoirement euh on
n'en veut plus non plus, il
existe aussi pour
l'hydroélectricité, j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure euh voilà
il euh une une anecdote une
anecdote marrante euh je sais
pas si vous le savez mais la
plus grosse centrale nucléaire
américaine fonctionne sans mer
et sans rivière, elle
fonctionne avec les eaux usées
d'une ville. Donc ce qui ce qui
sert de de de source froide
c'est les c'est les eaux usées
d'une euh d'une ville.
la question du coût Alors la
question du coût du nucléaire
est pour moi essentiellement
une euh une question de cadre
de marché. Euh vous savez, vous
avez probablement entendu
parler du coût du mégawatteur
de la centrale de Inklaypoint
euh qui va sortir un peu plus
de 100 livres, euh c'est-à-dire
quelque chose entre 100 et 150
euros de mémoire. J'ai fait un
petit calcul et en fait euh si
le financement de cette
centrale avait été fait avec de
l'argent disponible à 2 % par
an, et non pas avec de l'argent
disponible à 10 % par an, comme
c'est le cas, dans le cadre de
marché aujourd'hui ou les
acteurs prennent leurs risques,
et cetera. Le la même centrale
produit des mégawatts euh, aux
alentours de 50 euros. Donc en
fait le vrai sujet du coût du
nucléaire pour moi, c'est les
structures de financement et la
structure de financement dépend
essentiellement euh, du fait
que ça soit mis dans un cadre
public ou pas. Donc, je vais le
dire autrement, le nucléaire
pour moi n'a rien à faire dans
un cadre privé. Euh, c'est par
essence une activité qui est
régalienne euh, qui relève de
l'État et qui doit accéder à
des financements qui sont ceux
de l'État. Mais euh, j'ai j'ai
le raisonnement pour euh les
ENR euh je fais partie des gens
qui considèrent que d'avoir euh
fourni des produits financiers
à 15% de rendement sur capitaux
investis sur les premiers
panneaux solaires, c'était
quelque chose qu'il n'aurait
jamais dû exister hein. Euh la
question des déchets, alors
c'est une question euh qui est
très importante dans le débat
public, c'est-à-dire quand on
regarde euh de quoi les gens
ont peur euh quand il s'agit du
nucléaire, les déchets c'est
quelque chose qui
sanitaire euh, les particules
fines euh, et cetera. En fait
les déchets nucléaires pour moi
ça va peut-être faire sauter en
l'air quelques personnes dans
cette salle mais c'est vraiment
du du deuxième ordre, enfin
c'est c'est c'est c'est tout
petit euh, il y en a
quelques-uns, alors évidemment
c'est des franches saloperies
mais il y en a pas beaucoup
c'est confiné et cetera et de
très loin l'option
préférentielle c'est de les
mettre dans un trou et de les
oublier euh, c'est exactement
ce que les Suédois ont décidé
de faire euh, je considère que
le retraitement est une bonne
idée parce que ça permet de
concentrer le volume euh, qu'il
y a à stocker derrière de façon
très importante ça permet de
récupérer euh, un certain
nombre de choses qui sont
récupérables euh, dans les
assemblages usées par contre
euh, il me semble que le et et
et la réversibilité des du
stockage euh, je sais qu'il y a
des gens qui tiennent beaucoup,
personnellement ça me semble
pas crucial. Euh, il y a un
stockage non réversible qui
s'est fait de façon tout à fait
naturelle il y a 2 milliards
d'années dans une mine
d'uranium au Gabon, à Auclos
euh, où des réacteurs sont
apparus spontanément euh, il y
a oui oui il y a le il y a il y
a le détail dans quelques-uns
de mes ouvrages si ça je peux
vous donner les références ça
vous amuse euh, et donc euh,
déchets qui ont été produits à
l'époque, c'est-à-dire des
produits de fiction euh qui ont
été produits à l'époque, euh en
fait ont très peu migré euh par
rapport à l'endroit où ils ont
été formés. Et c'était il y a
2 milliards d'années. Donc je
suis pas du tout inquiet quant
au fait que si on les met dans
une dans une couche géologique
profonde, on est capable de
mettre du pétrole et du gaz
sous pression qui va rester là
pendant des millions d'années
et pourtant c'est fluide et
c'est à haute pression. Donc
dans une couche géologique
appropriée, on peut très bien
mettre quelque chose de solide,
euh c'est-à-dire des colis
vitrifiés et pas être très
inquiets sur le fait que tels
ébulons, ça va nous sauter à la
figure euh 50 ans derrière.
Dernière chose qu'il faut
savoir sur les déchets, c'est
que euh les produits de fission
au bout de quelques siècles
sont revenus au niveau de
radioactivité de l'uranium
initial. Au bout de quelques
siècles, oui mais enfin c'est
c'est moins que Notre-Dame
hein, euh bon. Qui est à l'air
libre. qui est qui est qui est
qui est à l'air non mais qui
est à l'air libre et qui est
donc qui est beaucoup plus
agressé qui est qui est
beaucoup voilà. Donc c'est non
mais c'est dire quelques voilà
euh c'est pour dire on souvent
le chiffre de 100 000 ans est
mis en avant en fait il faut
voir que la partie la plus
radio toxique euh de ce qu'on
produit ça vit pas du tout
cette durée-là c'est beaucoup
plus court. enfin euh qu'est-ce
que je pense du biogaz et de
l'hydrogène? Alors le biogaz
euh c'est quelque chose qui de
mon point de vue est
intéressant pour des usages de
niches. Alors le le biogaz est
une est une énergie dérivée de
la biomasse donc faire ce
qu'ont fait les Allemands,
c'est-à-dire faire des cultures
dédiées pour faire des grandes
quantités de biogaz et quelque
chose qui me parait pas du tout
pertinent. Par contre euh faire
du biogaz avec des déchets
agricoles euh ou avec des
couvertures intermédiaires. Et
ensuite s'en servir
prioritairement pour remplacer
les fossile de la mécanisation
agricole, ça c'est quelque
chose qui me paraît tout à fait
pertinent. Euh dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie
française, on propose euh
déconstruire le réseau de gaz
en France, puisqu'on propose de
se passer de gaz tout court,
euh qui est essentiellement
fossile aujourd'hui, donc du
coup l'injection dans le réseau
devient un peu moins
intéressante et enfin euh la
production électrique, elle
peut éventuellement être
intéressante à partir du moment
où on s'en sert pour remplacer
le gaz dans les usages d'hyper
enfin de de de dans les
turbines quoi dans dans dans
des usages d'hyperpointe. Mais
à ce moment, c'est plus
tellement le même installation
parce qu'il faut des grosses
installations euh histoire
d'avoir des quantités de gaz
qui sont pas complètement
ridicules. L'hydrogène pour
stocker de la production
électrique intermittente, le
rendement de chaîne est
extrêmement mauvais, il est de
l'ordre du quart. Euh
c'est-à-dire que vous perdez
soixante-quinze pour cent de
l'énergie électrique initiale
euh dans le donc il vaut mieux
si on veut absolument stocker
de l'électricité hum faire des
stations de pompage euh voilà
reste à convaincre quelques
habitants de Savoie que on va
noyer les vallées avec l'eau du
lac Léman. Hum.
Merci bien, on reprend une euh
le le tour des des groupes,
monsieur Bolo. Merci monsieur
le président, merci monsieur
Jancovici . Je voudrais revenir
sur deux points que vous avez
euh évoqués avec nous. Le
premier c'est l'accès aux
métaux qui conditionne notre
indépendance énergétique et
ensuite le deuxième point c'est
la disponibilité des ressources
qui est un facteur limitant
d'une économie. Mais une
économie ça produit aussi des
déchets ou des objets en fin de
vie qui ont une valeur selon le
principe de l'économie
circulaire. Vous nous évoquez
une énergie plus importante,
nécessaire pour extraire des
métaux à la teneur réduite dans
les mines, cette même quantité
d'énergie pourrait être
utilisée pour recycler les
métaux. d'ailleurs plutôt bien
au recyclage. Donc la question
est très simple, quelle est
votre analyse de l'économie
circulaire? Alors euh madame
Battistel.
Oui, merci Monsieur le
Président euh, merci beaucoup
euh, pour toutes les réponses
euh, fournies que vous avez
apportées, d'ailleurs ça nous
laisse assez peu de questions
maintenant euh, simplement
revenir euh, sur euh, l'objet
de notre euh, commission
d'enquête c'est analyser
l'éventuelle euh, perte de
souveraineté ou d'indépendance
euh, énergétique de la France
du coup vous nous expliquez
comme beaucoup d'autres euh,
qu'elle n'a jamais été euh,
atteinte et euh, pour se servir
euh, des erreurs qui auraient
pu être faites par le passé, on
on on a besoin de de de cette
analyse et je crois que c'est
euh, véritablement l'objet de
de notre euh, de notre
commission d'enquête. Vous nous
avez euh, expliqué que euh, sur
toutes les énergies finalement
l'indépendance, la souveraineté
est inatteignable parce qu'on
dépend de toute façon euh, d'un
matériau euh, que ce soit euh,
euh, pour euh, l'éolien euh,
pour euh, les pompes à chaleur
pour le pétrole pour euh,
l'énergie nucléaire et cetera
sur la question de de il y a
effectivement le stress
hydrique mais on a euh un
certain nombre d'études qui
nous dit euh quand même que euh
la courbe euh de pluviométrie
peut être très euh enfin très
euh oui fluctuante mais quand
même les quantités peuvent être
là et euh l'hydroélectricité a
cette capacité de stockage et
sa flexibilité qui peut
peut-être lui permettre d'avoir
une sortie alors je parle de la
grosse hydroélectricité et pas
de la petite dont vous avez
parlé ou de la micro. Euh et
vous euh d'ailleurs euh la
question des steppes qui dont
certain nombre de projets euh
sont sur la table, pas que dans
la vallée de de la Savoie mais
mais bien ailleurs. Euh est-ce
que vous pensez euh qu'il y a
euh une acceptabilité
suffisante pour aujourd'hui euh
voir euh arriver euh une steppe
dans une vallée euh auquel
qu'elle soit euh et ses ses
avantages de Step c'est quand
même euh à la fois la FlexB et
la question de la pointe euh
que l'on évoquait euh tout à
l'heure euh sur euh hum le
nucléaire bon vous avez
largement répondu à mon
collègue donc je ne vais pas y
revenir et j'avais une deuxième
question qui était sur sur euh
bah voilà je l'ai perdu mais ça
me reviendra euh probablement
en tout cas euh sur euh sur
cette question euh ah oui la
dernière question c'était euh
finalement euh si on écoute vos
propos euh on serait plutôt
dans la situation où il faut se
poser la question plutôt que de
savoir qu' l'énergie qu'il faut
produire, comment on réorganise
notre société pour in fine et
se passer d'un certain nombre
de productions qu'on aura de
toute façon plus dans les
années euh euh qui viennent.
Donc est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on est euh à ce stade de de
conscience euh des populations
et du monde politique
évidemment euh dans cette euh
orientation-là? Alors on va
encore prendre les questions de
monsieur Alphanda et de madame
Lernos comme on vous coiffe ici
notre tout. Je vous remercie
monsieur le président. Euh
monsieur Jancovici euh ben
merci pour vos propos. Vous
avez déjà répondu à une large
partie de ce que je voulais
vous demander mais bon sur le
principe euh sur l'hypothèse de
base de faire moins et et de
faire avec ce qu'on a déjà
prélevé euh c'est certain. Euh
je j'ai je dois avouer que
j'aime bien votre euh votre
point euh sur la différence
entre le l'indépendance et le
confort. Il y a probablement
peut-être plus de souveraineté
du côté du confort que de
l'indépendance qui est
peut-être assez illusoire, sauf
si on cherche des guerres. Euh
dans dans vos travaux, vous
l'avez clairement dit hein euh
on a à peu près plus qu'une
seule cartouche à tirer euh on
a 20 à 30 ans pour agir au
niveau mondial et ce qui est
extrêmement difficile c'est euh
c'est le phasage. C'est très
clairement, c'est d'arriver à
voir la différence entre ce qui
est mature, entre ce qui sera
intéressant et deviendra mature
à terme et la manière dont on
déploie l'ensemble de ces
solutions euh, à travers le
temps. Euh, typiquement c'est
ce que vous disiez sur le
réacteur de quatrième
génération euh, là j'étais avec
des gens du nucléaire qui me
disaient 50 ans pour la
quatrième, vous dites à si on
décide et qu'on y met la
volonté 15 ans, donc euh, voilà
la question de combien de
réacteurs on on déploie, quelle
génération on déploie? Pour
quelle jonction euh il y a
après dans dans vos travaux, il
y a je sais qu'il y a il y a
des il y a des points un peu
euh euh qui sont mis un peu de
côté, qui est clairement
l'identification de la
ressource. Euh par exemple, on
parlait des déchets juste avant
et de l'économie circulaire.
Euh il y a des procédés de
gazéification euh sur une
partie de choses qui ne sont
plus traitables, mais en même
temps, si on veut diminuer les
produits pétroliers, si on est
sur d'autres types est-ce qu'il
y a des plastiques euh qui sont
circulaires, sur lequel on va
trouver le même potentiel
hydrogène ou pas? Qui a le
problème donc des
dimensionnements industriels de
ce qu'on va faire et euh et
puis euh toute la question du
du du progrès euh par exemple
euh j'ai j'ai visité une
société euh qui fait de
l'impression 3D et qui
aujourd'hui fait des fait des
pièces euh qui sont beaucoup
moins lourdes, notamment pour
le transport ferroviaire euh
sans sans perte de matière,
c'est il y a il y a il y a des
gains probablement euh à
trouver par là. Et euh et
pareil dans vos travaux vous
vous l'esquissez mais mais on
prend pas trop en compte la la
question de de l'aménagement du
territoire. Dans les modes de
vie qu'on va changer, il y a
bien sûr des des usages euh
comme Marjol le disait qu'on
pourrait abandonner ou ou mais
il y a aussi la question de de
comment on occupe le territoire
et et comment on vit dessus. Et
ça c'est c'est extrêmement
difficile à prendre en compte.
Euh et puis enfin euh je vais
être un peu je le provoque euh
pour tous les blancs euh on
voit bien euh ceux qui
gagneront demain sont pas
forcément euh ceux qui perdront
aujourd'hui euh qu'il y a
l'accompagnement de ça et euh
moi ça me pose la question du
salaire universel par exemple.
Universel, dividende universel,
enfin ce que quelque soit le
nom en tout cas, quelque chose
qui qui qui vient euh
clairement euh accompagner les
gens dans cette mutation
profonde euh qui va toucher euh
nos systèmes économiques, nos
systèmes sociaux, nos systèmes
de production euh de
déplacement et et d'habitat.
Madame Lernos. Oui euh, merci
plusieurs euh, questions et
plusieurs réactions aussi euh,
tout d'abord euh, le chiffre
Project et euh, les travaux que
vous avez menés ont éclairé un
certain nombre de points
importants euh, notamment euh,
sur la sobriété euh, sur la de
prendre euh, de manière globale
les problématiques et vos
propos introductifs notamment
sur euh, avoir l'économie comme
donnée euh, sortante et non pas
entrante en fonction euh, des
ressources dont on dispose euh,
favorise la réflexion un peu
plus approfondie et globale
euh, plutôt que de se dire
qu'il y a une solution
technologique qui va sauver
euh, tout notre climat et euh,
nous préserver du réchauffement
climatique à venir et je pense
que l'accent n'est d'ailleurs
pas assez mis souvent euh, y
compris quand euh, on évoque
votre nom euh, souvent ce n'est
pas euh, vos propos ou vos
travaux euh, sur euh, la
sobriété, la rénovation, sur ce
que vous avez eu euh, comme
propos et qui sont dans vos
écrits aussi euh, notamment
euh, vis-à-vis du transport
aérien où là il n'y aura pas de
solution technique qui de
continuer euh à se déplacer
euh, sur des longs cours comme
nous le faisons aujourd'hui
mais qu'il y a là euh, dans vos
écrits de manière scientifique,
technique, établir euh, le fait
qu'il faut envisager une à une
autre manière de vivre et une
autre manière de partager aussi
les ressources qui me semblent
importantes sur lequel il
faudrait à mon sens euh, mettre
plus l'accent. Je reviendrai
sur euh, vous avez évoqué
effectivement la question du
consensus et je pense que vous
et votre nom aujourd'hui
évoquent pas mal de euh y
compris euh par rapport aux
écologistes euh puisque euh y
dans dans les dans les travaux
et puis dans les propos que
vous avez euh euh tenus euh y
compris sur la responsabilité
euh qui serait euh du euh à
l'accord électoraliste euh
entre le parti socialiste et
euh ma formation politique et
Europe Écologie Les Verts. Euh
ça serait là euh le début du
mot des mots et euh la perte de
souveraineté en tout cas en
matière de nucléaire. J'ai
envie de dire que pour euh le
physicien que vous êtes euh
dans le réchauffement
climatique et la lutte qui euh
nous rassemble toutes et tous
en tout cas dans les solutions
qu'on essaye d'y apporter et
d'y trouver. On sait très bien
que c'est les 15 prochaines
années qui sont cruciales
puisque les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre s'accumulent euh
aujourd'hui et provoquent donc
des un réchauffement climatique
qui va euh s'amplifier. Or euh
la solution qui euh semble
trouver euh la seule solution,
j'ai envie de dire qui semble
trouver euh la vraie grâce à
vos yeux, qui est le nucléaire,
ne pourra pas euh se déployer
de manière euh massive, comme
vous l'appelez de de vos voeux,
euh d'ici euh les 15 prochaines
années. D'ailleurs vous évoquez
euh sur euh les points de vue
technologiques euh entre euh le
PR troisième génération,
quatrième génération, on ne
sait pas exactement sur quelle
technologie on pourrait euh
s'appuyer pour euh lancer euh
d'un point de vue massif, vous
dites vous-même que c'est assez
euh utopique euh d'un point de
vue de réalisation parce que
tout n'est pas aligné euh dans
ce sens-là. Hum et donc euh
j'ai quand même une
interrogation réelle euh de
savoir quand vous faites euh
tous ces travaux et ces
travaux, on voit bien que la
fermeture de Fessenheim aurait
pu largement être compensée si
euh l'État français avait
réellement investi dans les
énergies renouvelables, avait
euh tenu ces objectifs et y
compris en matière de sobriété,
que ça soit euh dans les
transports ou euh dans tous les
potentiels, j'ai envie de dire
non activés, dans la rénovation
énergétique et thermique, on
voit que ça serait dix fois
supérieur à ce que était euh la
production de Fessenheim, mais
d'ailleurs les responsables à
ce moment-là euh que ça soit
RTE, y compris au sein d'EDF,
avec euh qui est intervenue ne
les investissements étaient
trop élevés euh dans la
sécurisation euh de la centrale
de de de Fessenheim pardon euh
à pour pouvoir la maintenir euh
ouverte et donc c'est euh là
une enfin j'ai j'ai une réelle
interrogation puisque je tout
semble conjugué pour vous vers
le nucléaire or il me semble
que si vous prenez les faits là
où on en est, les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qui vaut
euh aujourd'hui éviter euh euh
ça ne paraît pas le plus
logique y compris en terme
d'ingéni d'utilisation de
métaux, euh d'utilisation euh
d'importation puisqu'il faut
aussi euh importer euh
l'uranium. Et je voudrais
revenir aussi euh puisque vous
avez euh et vous êtes le
premier qui répond à la
question, ce que nous avons
posé la question à de
nombreuses reprises sur la
question euh du réchauffement
climatique et de la sécheresse.
C'est-à-dire que euh tout euh
les centrales nucléaires euh
sont euh construits à proximité
de cours d'eau. Euh on voit que
cet été euh en dehors des
problèmes de corrosion sous
contrainte et du vieillissement
du parc euh actuel. On voit cet
été euh on a autorisé euh, des
euh, dérogations au droit pour
pouvoir rejeter de l'eau plus
chaude euh, dans nos fleuves et
qu'on va euh, manquer euh, de
plus en plus d'eau et je ne
trouve pas très sérieux alors
que vos propos sont très
établis et factuels de dire que
on va utiliser l'eau des égouts
qui par ailleurs euh, peut être
relativement plus chaude pour
refroidir les réacteurs
nucléaires et puis on parle
dans le projet de loi
d'accélération sur le nucléaire
et également de déroger au
droit notamment pour construire
euh des euh nouveaux euh
réacteurs le long des côtes, or
on voit là aussi que le
réchauffement climatique euh va
engendrer une hausse euh des
niveaux euh de la mer et donc
euh j'ai une vraie
interrogation euh sur et un
vrai regret euh j'ai envie de
dire c'est-à-dire que autant
une grande partie de vos
travaux illustre et sont
importants et contribuent euh à
l'évolution des consciences et
des actes y compris dans le
secteur privé parce qu'on ne
pourra pas euh euh nos
émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sans accompagner et avoir
le secteur privé avec nous pour
s'interroger sur ce qu'on
produit, pourquoi on le produit
euh, pour autant euh, la
solution monomaniaque sur le
nucléaire me semble euh, pour
le coup créer du dissensus
alors qu'il nous faudrait un
consensus et euh, pour le coup
une vraie arme de guerre pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique qui euh, va plus sur
euh, la sobriété, la rénovation
et les énergies renouvelables
et il y a des scénarios qui
euh, comprennent tout cela et
qui euh, disent aussi que c'est
faisable, vous faites le choix
d'en choisir un autre euh mais
voilà, c'est ça mon
interrogation principale.
la la question est assez
simple, c'est-à-dire que vous,
la question euh, vous misez
euh, y compris en termes de
matériaux euh, disponibles, du
cuivre et cetera. Vous dites
euh, les énergies renouvelables
sont trop gourmandes, pour cela
et ne produisent pas assez
d'électrons. Vous dites qu'il y
a que le nucléaire qui peut
faire ça. Or, vous hésitez
vous-même entre les différentes
générations et vous dites que
les ENR sont là que pour faire
la jonction. Euh, or euh,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui contre le
réchauffement climatique d'ici
le fait qu'on puisse de manière
hypothétique construire de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires.
C'est-à-dire que même vous,
vous n'avez pas d'informations
ou de propositions fiables, sur
quelle génération? Vous nous
avez parlé de l'uranium 235 et
euh deux-cent-trente-huit et
puis euh sur euh les
propositions en terme euh des
ressources qui nous sont
dissovenues notamment les
ressources en eau pour
refroidir les réacteurs. Euh
pas non plus. Donc je je ne
comprends pas euh quelque part
euh malgré euh la richesse des
travaux et des propos, pourquoi
euh vous vous sur cette unique
voie du nucléaire? C'est ça ma
question. Mais merci beaucoup
euh monsieur Jean Coustine, on
va vous laisser répondre. Je
vous informe qu'avant je
prendrai une une dernière série
de questions après parce que là
comme ça on a fini le tour des
orateurs de groupe et on fera
une dernière euh série de
questions, j'ai noté trois
personnes encore. Euh voilà. Je
vous laisse la parole. Alors
euh où est-ce que j'en étais
dans euh
La première série de questions
concernant les métaux hein
c'est ça? C'est ça.
Alors quand on utilise le terme
d'économie circulaire, en fait,
il y a une petite méprise. Les
atomes sont recyclables,
l'énergie jamais. Euh donc il
faut bien voir que d'aller
récupérer des atomes là où ils
sont, c'est ça l'économie
circulaire hein, j'ai des
atomes, j'ai des molécules qui
dans un plastique, un polymère
hein et je vais essayer de les
récupérer pour en refaire un
polymère. Eh bien ça, c'est
quelque chose qui va quand même
vous demander de l'énergie.
Donc l'économie circulaire,
elle peut être une solution
partielle ou importante à des
questions de disponibilité en
matière en ressources. Par
contre, ça toujours, même
l'économie circulaire avec une
mise en oeuvre euh du enfin
avec la disponibilité d'une
source énergétique dans
certains cas de figure
l'énergie du recyclage n'est
pas considérablement inférieure
à l'énergie de la production de
matière primaire c'est
notamment le cas du papier. Euh
c'est un exemple qui est bien
connu parce que désancrer le
papier c'est très énergétique
et donc recycler du papier ça
permet assurément d'éviter de
couper les arbres puisque ça
permet d'éviter de de de enfin
ça permet d'éviter de
s'approvisionner en fibre de
bois vierge par contre sur le
plan strictement énergétique on
gagne énormément. Alors il y a
des métaux qui se recyclent
facilement, il y a des métaux
qui se recyclent beaucoup plus
difficilement. Les métaux qui
se recyclent facilement, c'est
les métaux qui sont peu alliés.
Par exemple le cuivre est un
métal qui s'utilise tel que, il
est généralement pas allié, on
ne mélange pas avec un autre
métal, se recycle extrêmement
bien, il est extrêmement
fortement recyclé. Vous avez
d'autres métaux qui s'utilisent
en étant alliés, c'est-à-dire
que ils se trouvent dans un
alliage et par exemple le
manganèse est un est un
adjuvant de l'acier et euh vous
avez pas d'usage de manganèse
pur, enfin très peu. Donc pour
récupérer du manganèse, en
fait, faut récupérer de
l'acier. Bon. Euh vous avez un
certain nombre de petits métaux
euh qu'on appelle les terres
rares euh qui sont dans
l'électronique par exemple, qui
sont diluées à des à des
concentrations qui sont
beaucoup trop faibles pour que
ce soit facile de les récupérer
dans les objets dans lesquels
ils sont. Donc on peut le
faire, mais avec des dépenses
énergétique s extrêmement
importantes qui peuvent être
éventuellement supérieures à la
dépense énergétique
d'extraction de la croûte
terrestre. Donc il y a pas de
en fait il y a pas de réponse
unique, euh unique pardon à
faire à à à la question que
vous posez euh là aussi il faut
regarder en fonction du métal
et cetera. faut bien voir que
souvent euh pour les métaux qui
valent un peu chers et qui sont
disponibles quelque part sous
forme un peu pure, les
opérations de recyclage elles
ont déjà lieu. Ça existe déjà.
Par exemple tout ce qui est
chute dans l'usinage euh en
général c'est des métaux qui
sont recyclés. C'est c'est très
rare que ces trucs-là soient
perdus. Parce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui est facile à
utiliser euh facile à recycler
et cetera. Euh les carcasses de
voitures euh c'est facile à
recycler. Vous les collez
directement dans le
convertisseur et ça va. Euh par
contre euh redis, il y a
d'autres métaux, c'est plus
c'est plus difficile de les,
c'est plus difficile de les
récupérer et il y a d'autres
sources, c'est plus difficile
de les récupérer aussi, par
exemple sur certains
plastiques, des polymérisés,
des plastiques pour les
repolymériser derrière, ça peut
être extrêmement compliqué, ça
peut ne pas être possible, euh
ça peut être
par le rayonnement ultraviolet
ou et cetera donc vous en
refaites pas l'usage initial,
c'est le fameux exemple de la
fourrure polaire qui est faite
avec des déchets de de de
bouteilles hein euh, voilà donc
euh, il y a il y a il y a des
choses à faire euh, c'est très
difficile de faire une réponse
générale donc il faut regarder
au cas par cas et bien
évidemment à chaque fois qu'on
peut gagner quelque chose il
faut le faire. Après euh il y
avait une question sur les
steps, c'est ça? Euh pourquoi
est-ce que on fait pas plus de
step et quelle est
l'acceptabilité pour en faire?
Euh ben l'acceptabilité est
faible comme pour euh à chaque
fois que vous avez l'intention
de construire quelque chose
quelque part. Euh donc euh on
la réponse un peu plus générale
que je pourrais faire c'est que
une des choses sur lesquelles
il faut arriver à se mettre
d'accord, mais c'est difficile
à installer euh dans le débat
politique par par jeu même du
débat politique. C'est l'idée
que euh les temps qui viennent
vont ne se prêteront à aucune
solution parfaite. Euh et donc
il va falloir accepter de façon
un peu partagée euh ce qu'on
considère être euh, le plus
faible inconvénient ou l'idée
qu'on se fait collectivement du
plus faible inconvénient euh,
et évidemment ça sera toujours
au détriment des gens qui vont
être localement concernés par
le plus faible inconvénient.
Donc si on décide que le plus
faible inconvénient c'est de
faire des steps, il y a quand
même des gens qui sont
localement là où on va faire la
step qui vont pas être d'accord
du tout. Euh, du reste euh, la
le le droit prévu depuis très
longtemps euh, que on puisse
passer par-dessus la tête de
ces gens-là hein, c'est les
procédures d'expropriation euh,
toute la question allait de
savoir collectivement où est-ce
qu'on met le moins de douleurs
pour le plus de bénéfices pour
la collectivité? C'est toujours
ça la question, sachant quà un
moment il y a toujours des
gens, il va falloir leur passer
par-dessus la tête, mais on a
exactement le même problème
avec n'importe quelle
installation qui demande de
couler du béton quelque part
hein, c'est voilà on a on a le
problème euh, on a le problème
partout.
alors après il y avait
tellement de questions euh il y
a il y a j'ai noté plein de
trucs euh
il y avait un sujet sur le
progrès, il y avait un sujet
sur l'aménagement du territoire
euh sur les ressources, sur et
comment se passer d'un certain
oui, comment installer la
sobriété? Euh je reviens à ce
que je disais tout à l'heure
euh le fait d'arriver à
installer la sobriété va avec
euh le fait que il y a un le
cadre physique dans lequel euh
nous devons raisonner à partir
de maintenant, ne nous laisse
plus toutes les options. Alors
il y a des domaines dans lequel
on le sait depuis longtemps.
Par exemple, si je bas des bras
dans cette pièce, je vais pas
voler pour autant, donc euh il
y a des degrés de liberté
physique qu'on a pas euh on le
sait depuis longtemps. Ce qui
est beaucoup plus désagréable,
c'est de d'accepter l'idée que
des degrés de physique qu'on a
eu, par exemple quelques heures
de Smic euh de monter dans un
engin qui va à huit-cents
kilomètres heure et qui vous
emmène à deux-mille kilomètres
de là où vous êtes. Euh on ne
l'aura plus. Euh ça c'est
quelque chose qui est compliqué
euh, et ça va nécessairement
avec une un mot que j'ai pas
encore prononcé jusqu'à
maintenant qui est le mot de
l'équité. Euh, il y a eu il y a
pas longtemps comme vous le
savez probablement un petit
débat sur la question des jets
privés, alors quand vous
regardez ce que représentent
les jets privés dans les
émissions du pays ou la
consommation de carburants du
pays c'est pas quelque chose
qui est absolument crucial. Par
contre, c'est très emblématique
d'un luxe ostentatoire euh qui
apparaît comme insupportable
euh à des gens qui vont devoir
faire des efforts sur des
gestes qui sont unitairement,
des gestes beaucoup plus
modestes. Hein. Et donc la
question de la sobriété pour
moi, elle est euh
fondamentalement associée à la
question un de la maîtrise de
son propre destin, donc ça
renvoie à la question qui a été
posée par votre euh collègue du
RN tout à l'heure sur euh
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
que des gens acceptent euh de
continuer à avoir l'impression
d'être maître de leur destin,
alors même que il y a des
choses qui physiquement leur
seront plus accessibles. Donc
ça, c'est quelque chose qui est
évidemment une question
cruciale. et euh ça va
également avec euh l'idée d'un
arbitrage entre moins de
liberté aujourd'hui pour plus
de liberté plus tard parce que
euh il y a aussi une question
qui a été posée sur la
démocratie, le fait de pouvoir
continuer euh du reste par le
même, euh le reste de pouvoir
continuer à vivre en démocratie
dans vingt ans, combien est-ce
qu'on est prêt à payer
aujourd'hui euh en kilomètres
en voiture non effectués pour
conserver ça, bon et c'est il y
a aussi ce genre de débat qui
doivent être installés dans la
population et c'est pas simple
d'illustrer ce genre de débat
pour plein de raisons, d'abord
parce que c'est pas simple
d'illustrer le monde dans 20
ans où Euh ce qu'il pourrait
être dans les mauvais cas de
figure dans vingt ans, c'est un
truc qui est compliqué. Et euh
c'est c'est c'est voilà, mais
c'est on on est clairement euh
dans une discipline un peu
nouvelle qu'on va devoir
apprendre, que j'appelle
parfois la hiérarchie des
renoncements, euh c'est-à-dire
à quoi est-ce qu'on est prêt à
renoncer, qu'est-ce qui va pas
être très coûteux finalement et
qu'est-ce qu'on a envie d'avoir
en face? Euh est-ce qu'on a
envie d'avoir en face un monde
euh qui nous paraît euh plus
plus assuré par exemple? Est-ce
qu'on gagne de l'espoir? Est-ce
qu'on gagne de la sérénité?
Est-ce qu'on gagne de la
sécurité? Est-ce qu'on gagne
des trucs comme euh qui ont pas
qui ont pas de valeur
économique stricte au sens mais
qui ont quand même une valeur
importante euh pour les
individus puisqu'on est sur le
sur le la question des la la
question du confort
psychologique et la question du
du des valeurs en fait. Euh
voilà il y a pas il y a pas de
réponse miracle donc là c'est
clair qu'on va tâtonner un peu
euh très probablement euh mais
il me semble qu'il est
important d'emmener le débat
sur ces terrains-là euh encore
une fois qui est la juste
répartition de l'effort euh et
le fait par ailleurs de tenir
un discours adulte à la
population et donc de pas lui
raconter trop de
carabistouilles euh sur le
cadre physique dans lequel on
va être obligé euh de de
réfléchir.
sur la question de
l'aménagement du territoire, là
je vous renvoie à la aux
travaux du shift récents qui
s'appelle Stratégie de
résilience des territoires, on
a fait euh tout un tout un
ensemble de travaux là-dessus
et c'est clair que là aussi il
faut déconcentrer pour partie
l'initiative face au problème
mais il faut la déconcentrer de
manière intelligente euh
c'est-à-dire que la bonne
manière de déconcentrer
l'initiative c'est de mettre
les gens en capacité de
comprendre hein pour moi c'est
ça la la le la première étape
première étage de la fusée de
façon euh et donc ça passe euh
comme pour les députés qui
n'ont pas été assidu à la
séance de formation qui vient
d'avoir lieu si j'ai bien
compris, euh ça passe aussi
pour euh les élus locaux euh
par le fait d'arriver à
comprendre ce qui se passe euh
où sont leurs marges de
manoeuvre et où est-ce que ils
ils doivent être fatalistes
quelque part même si c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'aime pas
euh parce que ils vont se
retrouver face à plus fort
qu'eux, il va falloir qu'ils
composent avec une évolution
qui va de toute façon prendre
place. Euh les on a la la
première recommandation
stratégie de résilience des
territoires, c'était de
consacrer 1% des budgets
sachant que il y a 10 % du
budget là euh pour plein de
communes qui vont être bouffées
par la hausse de l'énergie hein
1 % du budget a a de
l'acquisition de connaissances,
c'est-à-dire soit de la
formation euh des élus, des
agents et cetera soit de la des
études ad hoc qui permettent de
comprendre quelle est la
situation de départ avec les
forces et les faiblesses du
territoire sur lequel on est et
comment est-ce qu'on confronte
le territoire à un objectif
national euh qui est d'arriver
à se passer progressivement des
hydrocarbures euh sous
contrainte de métaux d'espace,
de biomasse et tout un tas
d'autres trucs et de
biodiversité enfin il y a tout
un tas d'autres trucs. euh
voilà et sur la question du
salaire universel, j'ai pas de
réponse à vous apporter euh en
France on est plus proche avec
les systèmes de solidarité que
nous avons euh que d'autres
pays de cette notion euh
puisque on a déjà un certain
nombre de revenus garantis dans
un certain nombre de cas de
figure, on a une un système de
chômage qui est qui est une
très bonne chose hein euh qui
qui permet de faire face à un
certain nombre de situations où
les gens sont sans ressources
euh je je n'ai pas les
compétences euh j'ai pas
réfléchi à la question pour
savoir si euh il faut aller
plus loin que ça et dans quel
sous quelle forme? Voilà donc
là euh Joker si j'ai envie de
dire c'est un peu hors de mon
compétences et j'ai pas
tellement de pas tellement de
questions. Alors après euh il y
a une question euh qui m'a été
posée euh enfin toute une série
de questions. Euh alors je vais
quand même faire une remarque.
Euh vous avez commencé par me
dire euh vous parlez beaucoup
de la sobriété, on vous voit
pas assez là-dessus, puis
ensuite vous m'avez traité de
monomaniaque du nucléaire. Mais
enfin si je parle beaucoup de
la sobriété, je peux pas être
un monomaniaque du nucléaire
hein. Je parle nécessairement
d'autre chose que du nucléaire,
bon. Alors si on m'entend que
sur le nucléaire, là il faut
euh vous adresser aux
journalistes, euh il faut quand
même savoir, oui oui, je vais
vous offrir une anecdote. Euh
lors du lancement du monde sans
fin, excellente BD que vous
avez sûrement lu, euh j'ai été
invité à la matinale de France
Inter. Ils avaient commencé par
m'inviter pour parler de
nucléaire. Je leur ai dit, je
n'irai pas. J'en ai marre qu'on
vienne me chercher juste pour
ce sujet, je n'irai pas. Bon,
et alors ils m'ont dit, est-ce
que vous voulez venir parler de
votre BD? J'ai dit ça, je veux
bien. Donc, en fait, la raison
pour laquelle je suis mis en
avant, est là en ce moment, là,
comme je vous parle, euh la
semaine qui vient de se passer,
j'ai dû refuser euh je sais pas
combien, entre 5 et 10
invitations à aller causer le
nucléaire dans la presse. euh
je c'est pas moi. Euh enfin
c'est pas moi. Je j'assume mes
opinions. Mais le fait que euh
vous ayez une presse qui adore
et que vous êtes bien payée
pour le savoir, euh les trucs
qui sont blancs et noirs, euh
une fois qu'on vous a collé
dans une case, euh c'est
difficile d'en sortir. Euh donc
par ailleurs, je je ne je
n'élute pas et je ne et je donc
quand je suis sur un plateau de
télé qui a dix questions, dont
une question sur le nucléaire,
ben je réponds à la question
sur le nucléaire. Je veux dire,
je suis pas là pour dire euh ah
ben non, celle-là, je répondrai
pas, j'ai pas envie euh, allez
donc voir quelqu'un d'autre.
J'assume. cela étant, si
derrière, le résumé, c'est
qu'on ne retient que ça je fais
ce que je peux pour lutter
contre, je ne maîtrise pas
complètement le processus. Donc
je je je m'exprime également
euh par d'autres canaux que la
presse euh en particulier je
m'exprime tous les jours sur
LinkedIn euh et je ne parle pas
tous les jours de nucléaire si
vous allez regarder hein euh
loin s'en faut. Euh je
m'exprime également sur mon
site personnel et je ne parle
pas que de nucléaire, loin s'en
faut euh donc et je m'exprime
dans des vidéos où je ne parle
pas que de nucléaires loin s'en
faut, je suis capable de faire
un exposé d'une heure et demie
sur la situation énergétique et
climatique en prononçant le
monucléaire deux fois, si je le
prononce. Donc euh voilà donc
la seule chose que je puisse
dire c'est euh autant que faire
se peut, j'essaye de renvoyer
les gens à mes écrits et à mes
oraux primaires euh après euh
la presse de temps en temps
vous la maîtrisez pas
complètement. Encore une fois
vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir.
Bon après je sais pas si vous
voulez que je réponde dans le
détail à tous les autres trucs
que vous avez. Bon j'ai compris
que vous aimiez pas beaucoup le
nucléaire euh. Mais bon je sais
pas si c'est la peine de
répondre en détail à tout.
sens de ma question. Ouais le
le sens de ma question est euh
moi quand je regarde bout à
bout les éléments rationnels et
dont vous faites y compris état
dans un certain nombre d'écrits
euh je n'aboutis pas à la même
conclusion. C'est pas une
question d'idéologie, c'est une
question de mettre bout à bout
les choses. Et c'est pour ça
que je vous posais la question
sur les 15 années, les le
réchauffement climatique et euh
sur l'incertitude quelque part
du développement de la
technologie qui que vous mettez
en exergue dans les options et
que vous défendez de fait euh
c'est ça qui m'interroge euh
réellement sur euh pourquoi
cette croyance quelque part euh
totale dans le fait que le
nucléaire sauverait le climat
ce qui moi me paraît
antinomique mais c'est c'est un
peu ça euh voilà c'était le
sens de ma question. Ça
m'intéresse quand même votre
réponse. Alors si vous avez
bien lu ce que j'ai écrit et
dit, je n'ai jamais dit que le
nucléaire sauverait le climat
, jamais. Euh j'ai toujours dit
que le nucléaire n'éviterait
pas la décroissance, toujours.
Euh j'ai toujours dit qu'il ne
serait pas à l'échelle pour
remplacer les combustibles
fossiles, toujours. La seule ce
que je dis, c'est que il fait
partie des amortisseurs de la
décroissance et dans cette
catégorie-là, je considère
qu'il a un certain nombre
d'avantages physiques qui font
que c'est une bonne idée d'en
faire autant qu'on peut,
sachant qu'autant qu'on peut,
ça sera jamais des montagnes de
toute façon parce que il y a
des limites temporelles et de
compétences sur son
déploiement, qui font que de
toute façon, et j'ai également
écrit dans le premier livre que
j'ai écrit, que l'énergie
infinie serait une absolue
catastrophe. Je l'ai écrit dès
mon premier bouquins, expliqués
si on était tous transformés en
Superman, vous voyez euh, ben
vous avez une tête qui me plaît
pas, je fais exploser cette
salle enfin donc ça sera une
absolue catastrophe que on est
tous de l'énergie illimitée
qu'elle soit propre ou sale
n'est pas le sujet. Donc j'ai
mais par contre j'ai toujours
dit que il fallait euh, dans un
monde imparfait et qui va
malheureusement l'être de plus
en plus hiérarchiser nos
possibilités d'action et
choisir en premier là où la
balance avantage inconvénient
est la plus intéressante. Or,
je fais partie des gens qui ne
croient pas pour des que pour
des raisons physiques, on ira
jusqu'au bout des scénarios de
déploiement des énergies
renouvelables diffusent,
électriques, intermittentes.
Donc j'ai trois adjectifs sont
importants, hein. Je pense
qu'on n'ira pas au bout. Parce
que il faudra c'est trop
complexe comme système il y a
quatre conditions physiques sur
lesquelles l'AIE et RTE ont dit
qu'il fallait arriver à
franchir une barrière, que pour
le moment, on est pas arrivés à
franchir euh il y a un petit
documents qui a été diffusé il
y a un an et demi je crois à
peu près, je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu, euh qui listaient
les quatre euh les quatre
conditions euh il y a un sujet
de stockage, un sujet
d'ajustement en fréquence euh
il y a un sujet de
disponibilité euh du du du il y
a un sujet de euh stockage
inter-saisonnier qui est un
truc euh très important enfin
bon bref il y a il y a un
certain nombre de conditions
euh et je pense que euh on y
arrivera pas. Donc à part or le
système nucléaire on y est déjà
arrivé une fois en France. Donc
on a fait la qu'au moins on y
est arrivé une fois. Donc euh
c'est exactement l'image qu'on
utilise euh dans le dans le
monde sans fin, euh ça fait
partie des parachutes de
secours. Mais vous savez en
parachute de secours, c'est un
truc dont vous avez pas envie
de vous servir hein. Déjà vous
avez dû sauter de l'avion parce
qu'il était en flamme et en
plus le parachute dorsal ne
marche pas. Donc euh voilà.
Mais c'est quand même quelque
chose qui à tout prendre euh
présente des avantages
supérieurs à ses inconvénients.
Voilà, c'est ça mon opinion En
ayant bien regardé. Mon opinion
sur le nucléaire date d'une
époque où je n'avais pas touché
un euro d'un acteur de la
filière nucléaire. Ça date du
moment où j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à la question
climatique, en fait,
chronologiquement, j'ai regardé
d'abord le climat ensuite j'ai
regardé le et ensuite j'ai
regardé le pétrole, j'ai
regardé chronologiquement dans
ces trois ordres-là euh et euh
j'ai donc j'ai j'ai à l'époque
j'étais pas j'avais zéro lien
économique avec ce monde-là,
juste j'ai été posé des tas de
questions et tant que j'avais
pas compris, j'ai continué à
aller poser des questions, bon
et c'est de cette époque-là que
je date euh, que date ma
conviction, que c'est une
énergie qui est à mettre du
côté des solutions et pas du
côté des problèmes, voilà. Mais
c'est pas parce que c'est à
mettre du côté des solutions
que c'est miracle. J'ai jamais
dit ça et je ne le dirai
jamais. Mais du coup on a
encore euh deux euh questions
que je vous propose de faire
euh assez des efforts massifs
de sobriété. J'insiste
là-dessus hein. Ça ne les
évitera pas. Ça les allège. Que
je vous propose donc de merci
beaucoup monsieur Jancovici je
vous propose de de faire des
questions courtes et
synthétiques madame Brûle-Bois
et monsieur Mazar. Merci. Euh
monsieur. Plaisir de vous
écouter, vous êtes euh une
figure incontournable de la
sobriété euh du de la lutte
contre le réchauffement euh
climatique. Vous parlez vrai,
vous parlez simple. Euh vous
parlez juste et vous plaisez
beaucoup aux aux jeune
génération. Votre chaîne
YouTube compte 220000 abonnés,
votre Facebook
cent-quatre-vingt-cinq-mille de
six-cent-mille abonnés. Pardon?
Voilà. Donc euh euh moi ce qui
m'inquiète voyez-vous euh c'est
euh c'est ce numérique qui est
sur la pente ascendante qui
augmente de 9 % sur un an et
bref euh ce numérique risque de
devenir euh insoutenable pour
la planète puisque c'est un
gouffre énergétique un grand
consommateur euh de matière
première. Donc euh le secteur
du numérique génère euh autant
euh de gaz euh à effet plus de
gaz à effet de serre que
l'aviation que vous avez
souvent citée et deuxmille
deux-mille-cinquante on nous
dit que à ce rythme elles
représenteront 35% des
émissions euh des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre. Donc euh
ma question est la suivante, ce
numérique euh qui a quelque peu
quand même bénéficié à
l'environnement euh ne suffit
pas à compenser sa propre
empreinte numérique. On a pensé
euh euh on a compté sur la
dématérialisation pour
économiser des arbres, mais au
bout du compte, quand on fait
l'addition, euh le compte n'y
est pas. Alors euh que
pensez-vous euh monsieur
Jancovici de ce de cette euh ce
développement exponentiel de
retweet euh futile inutiles?
Pensez-vous qu'il ne faudrait
pas euh aujourd'hui euh
réfléchir à responsabiliser
voire à réguler l'usage du
numérique? Merci monsieur
Mazar. Merci synthétique. Oui,
merci euh monsieur le
président. Désolé monsieur, je
vais vous obliger encore à
parler un petit peu de
nucléaire. Euh Quand on
rencontre nos nos concitoyens
donc deux craintes concernant
euh le nucléaire. La première
crainte et et vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure, c'est
euh quid des déchets et vous
avez dit que c'était peut-être
un peu disproportionné euh la
crainte qu'on pouvait avoir sur
euh le traitement de nos
déchets par rapport à la
technologie qui semble assez
euh assez euh assez euh
efficace en la matière. Et en
tout cas le le peu de risques
objectifs qui que que
représentent ces déchets. Et
après la deuxième crainte qui
est exprimée c'est la
sécurisation des sites
eux-mêmes. Des sites nucléaires
par catastrophe nucléaire ou
par rapport à des attaques euh
et et on voit ce qui se passe
en Ukraine actuellement. Quel
est votre votre avis là pour
euh pour pour pourquoi pas
aussi rassurer nos nos
concitoyens sur ce sujet ou
est-ce que c'est une crainte
qu'il faut prendre
véritablement au sérieux? Et
qui peut être un écueil au au
développement du du nucléaire.
Et puis euh euh un mot sur euh
sur l'énergie produit par euh
par nos nos grands ouvrages
hydroélectriques. Euh vous vous
savez que qu'aujourd'hui euh
certains nombres euh de ces
ouvrages sont exploités par euh
ben par euh des exploitants euh
historiques mais à qui on
demande donc euh euh de
remettre donc à la concurrence
donc enfin on demande à l'État
en tout cas de remettre à la
concurrence donc l'exploitation
de ces grands barrages euh
hydroélectriques alors là on
est sur un problème de
souveraineté euh qui est pas
lié à la technologie ou aux
procédures mais qui est liée
donc euh à celui qui demain
pourrait piloter ces ces grands
ouvrages quel est votre
sentiment sur le sujet et
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui euh
l'orientation qui semble être
prise concernant notamment
l'opérateur EDF avec euh la
nationalisation semble aller
dans le bon euh, dans la bonne
direction. Alors madame Gbagbo
et puis ensuite on aura fini
les questions. Merci monsieur
le président. Oui je voulais
tout d'abord revenir sur euh
les dérivés du plastique des
revenus du pétrole dont vous
évoquez si vous pouvez euh
éventuellement développer, vous
avez parlé de la mobilité des
bâtiments mais restait
effectivement les plastiques du
quotidien et notamment dans la
partie alimentaire. Euh la
deuxième question c'est sur le
bilan de sur le bilan carbone
vous en êtes l'auteur. On parle
souvent euh d'émissions carbone
mais bien moins de bilan et
pour nos prises de décision euh
je pense qu'il serait
intéressant et j'aimerais
savoir si ça si cela existe.
Alors dans dans de nombreux
domaines mais aussi sur
l'énergie. Un bilan euh carbone
sur l'ensemble des solutions
euh que nous avons évoqué
quelque chose de précis et de
clair qui serait euh ma
collègue le parlait tout à
l'heure de rationnel. Là au
moins ce serait intangible, ce
serait euh factuel. Merci.
Voilà alors on on vous la
parole, je vous je vous pose
euh une dernière question euh
un peu bonus. Euh voilà
privilège du président. Euh
cuite des des puites carbone
euh
autre que naturel, voilà. Vous
voulez parler de l'aspirateur à
CO2 Islandais là? Alors euh le
numérique. Vous avez raison,
j'ai mauvaise conscience. Bah
oui. Euh alors le numérique je
vais d'abord le relier à la au
thème de cette commission c'est
un domaine dans lequel nous
n'avons aucune souveraineté
aucune euh c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui pour payer mes
impôts je dépends des GAFA car
la fonction la plus régalienne
de l'État qui est de lever
l'impôt a été confiée au GAFA
j'ai besoin d'un ordinateur
j'ai besoin d'un système
internet qui est pas opéré euh
mondial de télécommunication
après je tout ça et il y a plus
rien de il y a plus rien dans
cette affaire qui relève de la
souveraineté française hein bon
euh le ce qu'on vient de faire
sur la 5G de mon point de vue
un abandon supplémentaire de
souveraineté puisque on va
obliger les Français enfin on
va on va inciter pour être plus
exact euh les opérateurs
français à s'équiper avec des
tas de composants de réseaux
qui sont pas fabriqués en
France euh on va inciter les
Français à changer de
smartphone pour des appareils
qui sont pas fabriqués en
France donc c'est quelque chose
qui est tout ça pour regarder
Netflix dans le métro, enfin je
suis pas complètement convaincu
pour avoir Tinder qui marche
mieux euh du reste au moins
Free et honnête dans ses
campagnes de pub euh donc le
l'opération du genou de madame
je sais pas quoi en creuse là
euh en fait non c'est pas ça
que ça va servir donc on a on
on est clairement aujourd'hui
dans ce que j'appelle l'ébriété
numérique. Euh alors avant de
savoir si la première chose à
faire est de fermer le compte
YouTube de Jancovici ce qui est
une option puisque et comme ça
en Superbarie ça supprimera de
la pollution numérique et ça
euh pour le moment je fais ce
que je peux on dit regardez en
très basse définition mais bon
euh c'est clair que j'y
participe aussi hein donc euh
ça question pour moi aussi. Euh
il y a quand même un alors si
on repart du début hein euh
l'empreinte carbone du
numérique aujourd'hui dans le
monde c'est à moitié
fabrication des équipements, à
moitié opération des
équipements. Euh dans les
équipements vous tous les
écrans connectés là qui sont
euh autour de cette table,
enfin autour de cette salle,
pardon, euh vous avez les
ordinateurs, vous avez les
smartphones, vous avez les
composants de réseau, euh
voilà, ça c'est et les
serveurs. Et le, la, le,
l'opération de ces équipements,
donc l'électricité euh c'est
l'autre moitié. Ce qui tire
aujourd'hui, extrêmement
fortement, donc vous avez
raison de me chatouiller sur
YouTube, euh ce qui tire
aujourd'hui extrêmement
fortement la croissance du
trafic euh du système digital
mondial, c'est la vidéo en
ligne. Hein, euh alors euh les
gens qui font du streaming, la
Netflix en euh YouTube est un
gros pourvoyeur également de
trafic d'atta euh le **** est
également un gros pourvoyeur de
trafic d'atta et après vous
avez toutes les vidéos du petit
dernier qui fait euh que les
gens s'envoient. qui est
quelque chose de nulle
importance pour en général pour
les récipiendaires mais très
important pour les gens qui
expédient la vidéo. Et euh donc
le donc la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on limite
l'inflation de tout ça? Euh
alors il y a quelques
suggestions qu'on avait faites
euh à l'époque au chiffre
projet. On avait proposé euh à
l'Arcep euh que les accords
enfin le que les licences
octroyées aux opérateurs soient
faites sous conditions de
maîtrise de l'empreinte
carbone. voilà, c'est une
option. Euh bah euh à l'époque
euh il il nous avait quà
moitié Ryonnais, enfin il nous
avait ils avaient noté l'idée.
Euh il faudra probablement,
c'est toujours pareil, à partir
du moment où on veut limiter un
usage, il y a que deux options,
hein, c'est les quantités ou
les prix, euh et au Chic
Project, on est un peu plus
communistes, donc on préfère
les quantités que les prix. Euh
on pense que c'est plus
égalitaire, de limiter par les
quantités que de limiter par
les prix. Il va clairement
falloir se poser la question,
et par ailleurs, aujourd'hui,
la débauche euh d'équipement
qu'on est en train d'utiliser
pour des usages totalement
récréatifs euh le métat verse
euh et cetera. Donc je ne suis
pas complètement convaincu
qu'ils vont aider à faire
pleuvoir ou à se sortir un peu
mieux euh de la situation qu'on
est en train de décrire ici.
C'est autant de composants
qu'on ne pourra plus mettre
dans des choses qui aujourd'hui
sont indispensables au
fonctionnement quotidien de
notre société, avoir des
banques aujourd'hui euh les
banques c'est quoi? C'est des
électrons et des ordinateurs
hein, c'est ça une banque
aujourd'hui hein, c'est
d'accord, sans sans sans
électronique ça n'existe plus
une banque hein, si demain
matin on devait revenir aux
billets de banque et au
comptable sur feuille de papier
euh, système explose bon donc
c'est ces usages-là qui sont
même si on dit beaucoup de mal
des banques par ailleurs euh,
il y a il y a il y a il y a des
usages comme ça qui aujourd'hui
sont devenus essentiels à court
terme et on est en train de,
entre guillemets, gaspiller des
ressources pour des trucs assez
futiles, au détriment de la
possibilité de garder des trucs
qu'on va devoir garder un peu
plus longtemps euh, plus
longtemps précisément, voilà.
Donc il y a un vrai sujet euh,
là-dessus. Il me semble que ça
justifierait également euh, des
investigations un peu plus
approfondies euh, de l'enceinte
dans laquelle je me trouve euh,
de se pencher sur qu'est-ce
qu'on fait en termes de
stratégie numérique dans ce
pays à part céder euh, à la
fascination devant le gadget
euh, et je suis désolé de le
dire à votre groupe, notre
président en tête hein. Alors
euh ensuite, en ce qui concerne
bah, oui on a quand même tous
vu au là de Las Vegas euh, avec
des lunettes virtuelles et
cetera enfin bon enfin je dis
c'est pas un secret d'État
hein. après il y avait un sujet
sur la sécurisation euh des
sites euh enfin la question des
accidents euh, sur les sites?
Alors les les un accident est
toujours possible, c'est clair
que il faut vivre avec cette
idée hein, euh, moi en sortant
d'ici je peux me faire
renverser par un camion je veux
dire c'est donc euh, un
accident est toujours possible
euh, la question c'est euh,
est-ce que compte tenu des
avantages que nous offrent les
dispositifs non accidentés on
est prêt à courir le risque de
l'accident et le risque de
l'accident aujourd'hui le plus
important c'est le risque de
panique en fait, c'est pas
tellement le risque, c'est pas
tellement le dommage euh
physique euh lié à l'accident,
c'est le fait qu'aujourd'hui le
nucléaire encore une fois j'ai
jamais percé complètement les
raisons de de tout ça euh
engendre des réactions qui sont
disproportionnées par rapport à
la cigarette, par rapport à la
circulation routière ou par
rapport à un aliment dont je ne
redonnerai pas le nom ici parce
que ça a déjà suffisamment fait
le buzz comme ça, euh mais
c'est non mais mais voilà, on
quand on regarde les risques
concours, en fait euh qui se
passe en cas d'accident sur un
réacteur à eau pressurisé, le
plus probable c'est qu'il se
passe la même chose que ce qui
s'est passé à Trima Island,
c'est-à-dire que vous perdez le
réacteur à l'intérieur de
l'enceinte de confinement,
point. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
euh si vous avez un conflit?
Alors à ce moment, le vrai
problème c'est euh est-ce que
l'accident, enfin la vraie
question c'est est-ce que
l'accident va rajouter de façon
massive des dommages par
rapport aux dommages du
conflit? C'est ça la question.
Euh donc la question c'est si
il y a un accident à Zaporija,
est-ce que ça change
significativement le bilan de
la guerre en Ukraine? Et la
réponse est malheureusement
non. Donc quand il y a euh un
dommage à une installation,
parce qu'il y a eu guerre, le
vrai problème, c'est la guerre.
C'est quand même ça le vrai
problème. C'est c'est c'est
bien ça qu'il faut comprendre
hein. Bon, après vous avez des
tas de manières de faire plein
de morts avec des dommages aux
installations de production
électrique et du reste dans la
même la la convention. J'adore
les guerres avec convention,
moi. Je veux bien que tu me
tues mais d'une certaine
manière seulement. Euh
normalement on ne porte pas
atteinte aux centrales
nucléaires quand on se fait la
guerre, mais on ne porte pas
non plus atteinte au barrage.
Figurez-vous. Et or, si vous
voulez faire beaucoup de dégâts
très rapidement ou beaucoup
mieux dézinguer les barrages
que dézinguer les centrales
nucléaires. Euh si on faisait
sauter le barrage de Vouglance
euh en en France euh ça
mettrait six mètres d'eau place
Bellecour euh à Lyon euh je
peux vous assurer que ça ferait
plus de morts que bon. Donc
c'est c'est donc c'est quoi la
c'est quoi la bonne réponse? En
fait elle tient dans un mot que
j'ai pas prononcé jusqu'à
maintenant qui est pédagogique.
Euh l'époque va probablement
demander que votre métier
comporte plus qu'avant le fait
de faire la pédagogie des
problèmes. Alors je sais bien
que pour un élu normalement on
fait la pédagogie des solutions
mais euh non mais de temps en
temps je pense que vous allez
pas couper au fait de faire
aussi la pédagogie des
problèmes de et pour la seule
manière d'y arriver c'est de
vous en imprégner vous-même
hein, c'est-à-dire d'être
vous-même euh capable euh de
maîtriser à peu près les sujets
euh sur le plan technique hein.
Alors ça en fait un de plus euh
je sais très bien que ça vient
en plus de la sécurité sociale
euh de la production agricole
euh de la façon dont on
enseigne le français au collège
euh et euh de ce qui se passe
dans les quartiers où il y a
trop d'immigrés. Donc ça vient
en plus de tout ça euh mais euh
il va falloir le faire quand
même.
Euh quand je dis trop c'est pas
un jugement de valeur, c'est
pour euh représenter le débat
public.
pardon?
Vous pouvez le laisser, c'est
c'est c'est c'est une figure de
style. Euh après euh il y avait
un sujet sur une question sur
l'hydroélectricité et du coup
j'ai pas noté la question, j'ai
juste noté que c'était l'Iro
euh avouez, alors l'ouverture à
la concurrence du site ouais
alors je me suis je me suis
exprimé de manière générale sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence
des systèmes électriques en
disant que ça avait été une
**** Et euh je le pense
toujours, que on a
essentiellement perdu notre
temps euh à faire quelque chose
qui n'a apporté aucun mais
aucun élément positif, rien. Ça
a servi à rien. Ça a servi à
enrichir des distributeurs, ça
a servi à divertir de la rente
par rapport aux propriétaires
des dispositifs de production,
ça a servi à créer des effets
de volatilité dans les prix de
marché dont en ce moment, on
est en train de voir les effets
à plein. Euh ça enfin ça n'a
servi à rien d'utile. Euh
voilà. Donc est-ce qu'il faut
aller encore plus loin dans
cette direction? Ben vous avez
la réponse, la réponse est non.
Qu'est-ce que ça de
rétropédaler euh sur ce sujet,
ben ça demande que euh la
France euh prenne son bâton de
pèlerin et euh et aille euh
commencer à militer et donc
faire la pédagogie du problème
aussi euh auprès de nos amis
européens puisque c'est une ça
dépend d'une décision en disant
que peut-être que l'époque
voudrait que on arrête ce genre
de système euh qui n'a
strictement aucun intérêt et
que on revienne à quelque chose
de plus intégré euh qui permet
de faire de la planification
sur le long terme parce que le
maître mot en matière de
système énergétique c'est de
planifi et quand vous avez un
marché ouvert, la planification
est impossible.
Donc
vous pouvez faire de la
délégation, on aurait pu faire
de l'ouverture à l'amont. On
aurait pu dire, bon, on fait un
duopole dans ce pays, quand on
en a marre d'EDF, on prend
Engie et quand on en a marre
d'Engie, on prend EDF. On sait
exactement ce qu'on a fait dans
l'eau, c'est ce qu'on vous avez
plein de dans dans les
infrastructures très
capitiques, c'est ce qui finit
par se passer, c'est-à-dire
vous avez un oligopole régulé.
On peut discuter de savoir s'il
y a un oligopole régulé, c'est
mieux qu'un monopole. D'accord?
Mais c'est le seul truc qui
est, qui, qui, qui soit
compatible avec le fait que
vous avez besoin d'opérateurs
capables d'assumer des
investissements lourds. Voilà.
la concurrence à l'aval était
un truc qui n'avait aucun
intérêt. Aucun. alors les
usages du plastique euh on peut
faire de des plastiques avec de
la chimie avec de de la
biomasse euh puisque dans les
hydrocarbures vous avez du
carbone et de l'hydrogène donc
euh dans la biomasse vous
pouvez récupérer du carbone et
de l'hydrogène et après pareil
euh faire des faire des
plastiques. Du reste
aujourd'hui vous avez des
plastiques qui sont faits à
partir d'éthanol de canne à
sucre euh à partir euh d'un
million de maïs et cetera.
Est-ce qu'on en fera autant que
euh le plastique qu'on fait
avec le vrai pétrole, je ne
sais pas. Est-ce que ça sera
aussi facile ça non? Ça sera
nécessairement plus ****
piquer. Et après euh la
question c'est à partir du
moment où on se tape dans la
biomasse euh en fait il y a
toujours une question
systémique à laquelle il faut
être enfin le système à
laquelle il faut être capable
de répondre. La biomasse
c'est-à-dire l'espace, vous
pouvez en faire quatre choses
différentes. Vous pouvez vous
en servir pour manger vous
pouvez vous en servir pour
avoir des matériaux, des
fibres, euh du bois, du
chanvre, du lin euh et cetera,
du coton. Vous pouvez euh vous
en servir pour avoir de
l'énergie du bois bûche cette
fois-ci, pas du bois d'oeuvre.
Euh des carburant et cetera et
vous pouvez vous en servir pour
fish la paix à ce qui s'y
trouve, ça s'appelle préserver
la biodiversité. Et de temps en
temps vous pouvez un peu
combiner les usages. Par
exemple, vous pouvez faire une
agriculture qui soit plus ou
moins nocive pour la
biodiversité. Donc vous pouvez
avoir des des des combinaisons.
Vous pouvez faire de
l'agriculture avec de
l'agroforesterie, avoir un peu
de bois énergie, ou avoir un
peu de bois matériaux, hein. Un
peu combiné. La question de
combien de biomasses on est
capable d'utiliser pour faire
du plastique? Elle est donc
indissociable de la question de
combien de biomasses j'ai envie
d'utiliser pour avoir de
l'énergie, hum, bioga aux
carburants et cetera. Combien
de biomasses je veux pour faire
du bois d'oeuvre? Euh combien
de et cetera. Et aujourd'hui,
la seule chose que je peux vous
dire, c'est que quand vous
regardez les plans sectoriels
qui sont faits par les secteurs
industriels, les uns derrière
les autres, ça boucle pas.
C'est-à-dire, si vous ajoutez
simplement l'appel à la
biomasse du secteur aérien et
du secteur de la construction
pour avoir du bois d'oeuvre,
déjà ça, en France, vous
excedez les capacités de
production à surface constante.
Rien que ça. Bon. Donc euh
voilà, donc c'est en vous
disant ça, euh je ne je vous
explique pourquoi je ne suis
pas capable de répondre la
question parce que euh la seule
bonne réponse c'est ça dépend
de ce que vous avez comme
ambition sur les usages
concurrents euh de la biomasse.
Il y a pas de bouclage
aujourd'hui qui est fait euh
entre secteurs. Alors dans le
cadre du plan de transformation
de l'économie française, nous
on a fait ce bouclage et on l'a
tellement fait que on met très
peu de biomasse euh dans le
PTEF à cause de ça. Il faut
bien voir aussi quà l'avenir,
le changement climatique va
peser sur les rendements
agricoles. La décrue de la
disponibilité fossile va peser
sur les rendements agricoles,
puisque en fait, quand on mange
aujourd'hui, on mange et du
gaz. On mange du pétrole dans
la mécanisation des engins de
transport et dans les
transports à Mont et Haval,
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure et
on mange du gaz dans la
fabrication des engrais azotés,
qui sont faits avec du gaz.
Bon. Donc dans la décrue, on
mange également des engrais qui
sont importés de très loin, des
phosphates et de la potasse euh
c'est c'est de l'exploitation
minière hein. Donc avec ces et
on mange enfin du pétrole pour
les phytosanitaires. Bon. Avec
la décrue de tout ça, euh on va
vous savez que la mécanisation,
les phytosanitaires et les
engrais ont fait ont multiplié
le rendement céréalier en
France par 5 en 30 ans après
hein, c'est évident que dans un
monde avec un climat plus
hostile et avec moins de
combustibles fossiles
disponibles, on va avoir une
partie du chemin inverse qui va
se faire. Question, est-ce
qu'on accepte par exemple de
manger moins de viande en ayant
pas plus de surface agricole?
Est-ce que on veut plus de
surface agricole pour manger
toujours autant de viande? Du
coup vous aurez moins de
surface agricole pour faire du
bois d'oeuvre, du bois énergie,
euh et pour faire des
plastiques, enfin vous voyez,
donc c'est très difficile euh
de répondre à cette question-là
euh de façon euh dissocier, de
la façon dont on répond à plein
d'autres questions, y compris
euh sous contra enfin ou en
incluant plus exactement la
contrainte d'approvisionnement
énergétique fossile et la
contrainte de dérive climatique
euh qui sont plutôt des choses
qui vont jouer dans le mauvais
sens globalement. Donc la
réponse pour faire court, c'est
qu'il va falloir en utiliser
moins. et manger moins de
viande, c'est pas où, c'est
voilà et après il va bien il va
falloir bien la choisir, donc
typiquement dans le moins de
viande qu'on mange c'est
évident qu'il faut d'abord
commencer par euh, préserver ce
qui vient des pâturages parce
que c'est des endroits où vous
valorisez plus facilement de la
biomasse avec des animaux et
moins avec ce qui vient, des
grandes cultures qui vont
servir derrière à nourrir des
animaux et cetera. Enfin bon il
y a tout un débat à avoir
là-dedans également qui est un
débat pas simple et il faut
bien voir aussi que euh, il y a
un vrai sujet dans cette
affaire, c'est un un aparté
mais euh c'est très difficile
de demander à un secteur qui
est pas globalement pas très
riche à l'exception de quelques
acteurs mais euh qui est
l'agriculture euh de faire des
innovations massives euh sans
que les Français acceptent de
payer leur nourriture un peu
plus cher hein donc on a aussi
un sujet à ce niveau-là. euh
alors il y avait le bilan
carbone des sources énergétique
alors oui il y a des sources
énergétique sur lesquelles
c'est très simple de faire une
empreinte carbone par exemple
tous les modes électriques
c'est raisonnablement simple
avec parfois des variations par
exemple un panneau solaire
selon vous le mettez dans un
désert chillien ou selon vous
le mettez euh dans la brume
norvégienne il va pas vous
sortir la même quantité qui est
le même panneau solaire, qui
aura euh émis la même quantité
de CO2 pour sa fabrication
parce qu'il faut de la
métallurgie, parce qu'il faut
fondre le silicium, parce que
et cetera euh il vous fera pas
la même quantité de kilowatts
heure à l'arrivée sur sa durée
de vie et donc le contenu
carbone en analyse de cycle de
vie du kilowattor produit aura
varié par la force des choses
mais on a quand même des ordres
de grandeur. Donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est assez
facile à établir là où ça
commence à devenir plus
difficile, c'est pour certaines
énergies fossiles, d'estimer
les émissions dites fugitives,
c'est-à-dire les émissions qui
sont liées à les fuites à
l'amont et particulièrement
pour le gaz euh puisque le gaz
naturel c'est du méthane et que
le méthane est un gaz à effet
de serre. Donc les fuites de
gaz naturel euh de mémoire, je
voudrais pas dire de bêtises,
mais de mémoire à 10 % de à ou
8% de fuite, le gaz naturel est
aussi nocif que le charbon. Euh
pour voilà, 8 pour cent on les
a pas en général hein mais
c'est c'est quelques pour cent
on peut les avoir. Euh bon donc
il y a il y a voilà après pour
des là où ça devient plus
compliqué c'est pas tellement
pour les sources énergétique
c'est pour tout ce qui est en
tissu c'est-à-dire si je veux
faire l'empreinte carbone de
votre foulard ou l'empreinte
carbone de votre veste ou
l'empreinte carbone de votre
micro là ça devient plus
compliqué euh parce que à
chaque fois il faut faire une
investigation approfondie. Sur
les sources énergétique
globalement euh les ordres de
grandeur sont assez facilement
disponibles. Là où vous allez
avoir une incertitude
importante, c'est sur les
sources issues de la biomasse
parce que ça renvoie à la
discussion qu'on a déjà eu
plusieurs est-ce que c'est
associé à de la déforestation
ou pas? Parce que ça change le
résultat d'un ordre de grandeur
hein, en gros, si c'est pas un
socia de la déforestation,
c'est mieux que le fossile,
mais si c'est associé à de la
déforestation, c'est pire que
les fossiles. Donc euh c'est là
là il y a là là il y a quelque
chose qui est vraiment un un
j'ai envie de dire ça ça fait
vraiment changer de résultat de
nature. Euh et c'est lié à
quelque chose sur lequel vous
pouvez faire difficilement
autrement que de poser des
hypothèses.
Alors le euh ben dans dans les
plus émissives, vous allez
trouver en CO2. Euh ça dépend,
ça dépend sur quel paramètre
par ailleurs, parce que vous
pouvez regarder le CO2 et vous
pouvez regarder l'espace au
sol. Euh vous pouvez regarder
euh les particules fines?
Voilà. Alors si on parle de
CO2, ce qui est la plus nocive
de très loin, c'est le charbon.
Ensuite arrive le pétrole,
ensuite arrive le gaz. Mais le
bois avec déforestation, c'est
encore pire que le charbon.
D'accord? Donc par exemple, les
projets qui visent à remplacer
pour euh un certain nombre de
pays où le bois de feu est
obtenu par déforestation, les
foyers, par des petits réchauds
à gaz, c'est pas idiot. Hein?
parler de foyer solaire hein.
Je je je du but à gaz de
camping hein c'est voilà. Donc
euh vous vous avez un donc
c'est ça la hiérarchie. Dans
les modes euh donc dits non
carbonés c'est-à-dire où le
fonctionnement même n'émet pas
de CO2 euh la hiérarchie c'est
que vous allez trouver au plus
haut vous allez trouver le
solaire. En dessous vous allez
trouver à peu près à parité,
l'hydroélectricité, l'éolien et
le nucléaire avec des petites
variations euh en fonction des
spécificités locales euh voilà.
Mais en gros c'est comme ça que
ça se avec un facteur trois
quatre, on va dire, entre le
solaire et le euh, et le reste.
Le reste, vous êtes entre 5 et
10 grammes de CO2 par
kilowattheure électrique. Le
solaire, vous êtes entre 20 et
50, en fonction de, des
conditions d'insolation euh, et
cetera.
Ça c'est sans tenir compte du
stockage parce que quand vous
stockez euh vous perdez 20 à 40
% enfin avec des modes
classiques euh donc soit step.
Step vous perdez vingt-cinq
pour cent, batterie, vous
perdez 20 % et il faut faire la
batterie. Ce qui émet également
du CO2. Comme vous le savez
probablement dans une voiture
électrique, la fabrication de
la batterie c'est la moitié des
émissions de fabrication de la
voiture. Donc si vous rajoutez
les émissions du stockage euh
pour le solaire, vous pouvez
dépasser les 100 grammes. en
mode purement électrique, le
gaz est à 400 grammes de CO2
par kilowattheure électrique,
euh le pétrole à 800 et le
charbon à mille, en ordre de
grandeur.
les puits de carbone
technologiques bon en très en
très court vous oubliez. euh il
y a un truc qui
technologiquement peut
fonctionner, c'est de ne pas
émettre, c'est-à-dire la
capture et séquestration mais
récupérer le CO2 une fois qu'il
est dans l'air avec des modes
technologiques, ça c'est un
truc de Chadoc. Euh le CO2 est
une molécule qui est
chimiquement inerte, c'est
chimiquement inerte hein le
CO2, une fois que vous avez une
molécule chimiquement inerte,
diluée à zéro virgule04 dans un
milieu aussi peu dense que
l'air, oui. Eh bien euh pour
aller récupérer le CO2
là-dedans, vous avez une
dépense énergétique qui est
tellement considérable euh que
en fait euh c'est un truc que
vous ne pourrez jamais déployer
à l'échelle. Alors j'ai fait un
petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur avec le truc islandais
là euh qui a fait un peu le
buzz, l'aspirateur assez en
deux islandais. Et mon calcul
c'est que si on voulait avec ce
genre de dispositif qui
s'appelle dans le jargon
anglais capture donc euh dack.
Euh la totalité de nos
émissions annuelles hein
reprendre dans l'atmosphère
après avoir émis la totalité de
nos émissions annuelles, il
faudrait y consacrer la
totalité de l'électricité
annuelle et la totalité du
pétrole qu'on se met euh dans
le monde tous les ans. Donc en
gros on aurait un truc de
chadoc parfait où l'énergie ne
servirait une chose, c'est à
récupérer le CO2 qu'on met dans
l'air grâce à la cause de
l'énergie. Voilà, bon, je je
suis pas complètement persuadé
que ce soit quelque chose euh,
derrière lequel il faut se
précipiter. Donc aujourd'hui,
comme l'argent coule à flots
partout euh, parce qu'il y a eu
de la création monétaire dans
tous les sens, vous trouvez
quelques fonds d'investissement
qui investissent dans ce genre
de truc. Euh, mais c'est voilà,
ça ça les occupe mais en gros,
ça ne servira à peu près à rien
euh, pour changer le destin du
monde. Merci donc euh, pour
cette conclusion par laquelle
vous nous nous inviter à penser
que euh, pour l'instant euh, le
le génie de l'homme n'a pas
encore régalé la photosynthèse
en gros. Le génie de l'homme,
le génie de l'homme va avoir
beaucoup de mal à égaler un
certain nombre de merveilles de
la nature, vous savez? On est
d'accord là-dessus. Merci
beaucoup Monsieur euh,
Jancovici euh, pour euh, les 2
heures et demie que vous avez
consacré à à répondre aux
questions de notre commission
d'enquête. Euh, ça permet de
brosser large et de et de
progressivement entrer euh,
euh, dans les sujets qui seront
peut-être davantage des
processus décisionnels que euh,
euh, les les choix parce que ça
contribue aussi à la façon dont
on on prendra dans le dans le
futur euh les décisions
publiques. Euh merci à à toutes
et à tous pour votre
participation et puis je vous
dis ben à la à la semaine
prochaine Monsieur le
rapporteur. À la semaine
prochaine monsieur le
président.